c'était c'était une mascarade qui a duré
pendant pendant neuf jours
enfin n'importe quoi en fait enfin ce
qu'on a vu c'est c'était n'importe quoi
alors après je lis des gens çà et là qui
se donne neuf vous êtes anti maxime
parce que bas n'ont passé aucun rapport
en fait la malle trucks qu'on l'a dit
avant toi donc dans le temps dont il
n'ya pas d'anti ou de projeter pas quoi
c'est de la merde
j'adore en remettant un ton très posé
c'était de la merde
non mais quoi dire d'autre larry non
mais c'est un petit tu as she deux
secondes je n'organise pas ce truc et
puis la presse je sais pourquoi ils
l'ont fait un c pour leurs intérêts
économiques
ils ont soutenu ce croire très malin à
aller qu'on du food et de tous les
sports ne joue pas c'est une aubaine
tout on va nous regarder et ça a été un
truc complètement et gaullistes les
inconscients ils le prix maintenant
voilà qu'il ya un juste retour des
choses
mais du coup mais là je suis content
c'est que oui tout le monde va vraiment
regardé du coup vous avez raison mais
pour vous pour un thé du doigt quoi
passe et vous êtes ridiculiser enfin
c'est une nouvelle fois les échecs
ridicule et pas à la hauteur des
événements internationaux jamais à la
hauteur de rien en fait on peut dire
l'autre magasin on avait dit depuis le
début donc le talon de condom restent
droits dans ce qu'on raconte
et c'est comme ça ne pas en dire plus
j'ai déjà dit sur l'aide de youtube bat
a déjà tout dit ouais t'as pas tout dire
rapidement de manière concise
c'est juste vraiment moche viser des
joueurs quoi c'est un manque de respect
total way fait maison prix normal enfin
les arbitres aussi je la poule est les
gens qui sont venus ont pris des risques
qui sauvent et de leurs familles pas
forcément tous les rentrent ils ont pu
être soucieux ils ont dû vivre des
quarantaines et ses textes à tout ça
pour rien alors que justin a dû à ton
tournoi - tu faisais pas subir tous à
tout le monde ouais on dit et ce qu'on
les plus sains pour le communiqué
officiel mais apparemment c'est juste
parce que les avions sont cloués au sol
donc on arrête le ton à ce que les
avions ne volent plus bas devront enfin
on est on est vraiment dans le ridicule
quoi fab
on en est on est
on est dans le fabuleux corona là non ça
allait avait là les avions volent plus à
la joue plus aux échecs
j'irai la voir enfin rennes avec le
corps n'a du coup notamment
non mais il va en tout cas on a bien
géré la situation génère 20 août à
conneries au bout d'un moment fait déjà
ce que je veux dire c'est parti tu fais
ton il n'aurait jamais dû être joués
baba où tu as su que je dis non monsieur
claude en plus là ce n'est même pas
garantie que tout puisse rentrer chez
soi assez loin derrière soi dit en
passant mon pote
oui il fallait arrêter un jour avant en
fait il fallait arrêter après la ronde 6
y avait un jour de repos pour la suite
offs qui t'anime on ne peut pas après la
ronde 6 parce que bas le cycle à la
automatique pour sauver le chien s'était
quand même problématique pour le cycle
el fahm aux autres cycles du champion du
monde raphaël l'humanité repose
là-dessus en vain donc là bon on ne s'y
sont pouvait pas mes rondes s'être
finalement baron peut pas finalement
plus bon là aussi que c'est moins grave
vu que les avions ne volent plus là
butin n'a le cycle non ça passe après
avait donc c'était que le cours n'a la
santé non ça ça va là où le cycle a
peut-être j'ai pas pour rentrer chez moi
où les officiels de la fille de la oumma
est bloqué alors on nous ment on regarde
les partis déjà je bats soi disant oui
donc c'est ce qui est prévu mais alors
écoutez ce qui est prévu et on verra
parce que je sais pas enfin je sais
vraiment pas comment ça se passe et
c'est bon moi je serai radjabov du coup
je vous ferai un petit crossac bah oui
je serai des joueurs ici tout le monde
rêve homologué ce qui a eu enfin à tout
jamais et puis bon gars ils pleurent des
procédures une paire des trucs
après je sais pas comment chacun se
comporte très bien se passer et que ça
rejoint trois mois et tout va bien mais
c'est de toute façon de toute façon
femme quoi qu'il en soit l'équité
sportive n'a pas été respectée pour ce
tournoi car c'est une mascarade
oui non monsieur c'est joli non mais je
le répète ce que les gens c'est qu'ils
viennent qui partent ou quoi mais genre
c'est quand même un point quand même
assez fondamental je trouve de du
problème de ce tracé qu'il ya mois passé
c'est n'importe quoi comme dirait vlad
non monsieur c'est flou
et bon ben voilà du coup on verra on
suivra ça quand ça reprend un dur à dire
mais on conserve en quoi ça va être
quand même compliqué parce qu'il va
falloir enfin jamais en fait un nom mais
je sais pas quand ça peut reprendre
parce que l'on dit dans deux mois dans
trois mois je pense pas que la situation
soit vu dans mais maintenant en fait le
truc c'est que quand bien même dans ton
pays tu a résolu le problème date y en a
d'autres où c'est pas résolu que les
gens sont bloqués chez eux les
frontières sont parés de vert
enfin maintenant dans un encart joue en
deux ans ou dans dix ans je sais pour
trait les phares et et igo vidéo et j'ai
vu deux trois autres personnes dans le
chat c'est pas parce que nepomniachi a
perdu hier qu'ils ont arrêté le tournoi
final assez russe a perdu on arrête le
foot les avions au sol parce que
développeur douche parce que le cycle
sur ta du monde c'est peut-être pas un
russe donc non ça n'a absolument aucun
rapport avec ça le fait que ce sont la
russie soit des dérobades alors que les
poubelles il est co leader et je pense
pas que ce soit dans son intérêt
d'arrêter le tournoi a vu la méforme de
caruana qui pourrait revenir en forme en
dedans dans un deuxième en 2023 non non
ça n'a aucun rapport
ça n'a aucun rapport ouais non mais du
coup ça va être fou pour les gens
rentraient chez eux ce qui est très peu
d'un long de ligne les frontières
question tous les pays sont fermées je
sais même pas où ils ont témoigné
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué mais on
n'a jamais dû mettre les gens sont les
joueurs les arbitres mais là même le
personnel de l'hôtel
ça va peut-être que ils vivent là bas où
je suis donc allée des contacts avec des
serveurs au restaurant etc
car ils font ils ont fait prendre des
risques à tout le monde pour et on parle
même pas de la cérémonie d'ouverture
la cérémonie d'ouverture fab mille
personnes c'est hallucinant c'est
vraiment hallucinant ce qui s'est passé
pendant ces deux jours ces voix là tu
vois moi ski ski ciment bête tu vois
c'est même pas ça c'est que tu as tout
l'amateurisme des échecs à longueur
d'année qui qui qui est vraiment pour
moi cristallisé par ce par par ses
décisions en fait parce que j'ai je
trouve que c'est en fait c'est ça toute
l'année mais les gens sont peut-être pas
compte mais en fait c'est ça depuis des
décennies en fait on fait n'importe quoi
et là c'est juste un truc qui est
visible pour tout le monde mais bon on
pourra reparler des cadences on peut
reparler du nombre de tournois qui a du
manque de sponsors parce que c'est c'est
tout fait comme ça en fait fabre bombay
postes pour des baltringues
[Musique]
quelques semaines avant son ouverture on
faisait pareil en france et chinois
devraient au dialogue c'est pas faux
c'est pas faux tant que c'est pas chez
toi tu prends pas le truc au sérieux oui
mais la halle quand même quand le jour
où le tournoi commence et qui devait
quand même le problème sérieux année le
bon enfin que les russes de bonnes
chaussures et ok mais en fait vu que des
gens de toute la planète
plein de gens le prennent au sérieux
qu'ils étaient même présents sur place
puis tu avais le problème des joueurs
qui pouvaient tavoris ils prennent juste
de digues qui par voie on va se répéter
mais kia qui t'a impose deux mois
quarantaine avant de jouer face c'était
quand même tu as partant là de toute
façon est quelque chose qui n'allait pas
bon voilà bon du côlon en tout cas
aujourd'hui bah du coup écoute comme ça
avec les gens allaient venir qui vont
nous parler à gauche à droite ont fait
une petit aréna un peu plus courte mais
à midi et demi j'ai mis d'accord que je
me suis que les gens disent allez venir
tailler des gens qu'elle a émis des pour
la partie que ça allait demander man in
any pourquoi ça joue pas non plus à
personne c'est ainsi qu'à l'aréna et on
fait quoi on joue nous on fait de la
pédagogie on commente les parties ont
fait on commente aujourd'hui
ok j'ai peut-être donnant jouera quoi
enfin je bois dont on fait aujourd'hui
on commente on regarde un peu non ce
juge tout le monde doit recevoir de
kolontar ton pote qu'à ses enfants sont
peu un peu regardé les rakes enfin voir
du haut niveau voire un tournoi qu'il ya
un enjeu certain qui va aller à son
terme quoi fin mai en fin de droits dus
à son terme la tension bah oui mais
est-ce que tu sauves le cycle est ce que
le cycle va être sauvé
le cycle 2
rehnab les arénas lire la suite offs qui
jouissent tournoi très intéressant les
arénas bitstream
vraiment il ya que des codes et prévient
le classe comme la rétention et des
platines des diamants d or sont tous là
quoi tous les métaux sont représentés
ouais ils sont de partout attends je
viens et je repars pas fou je suis là
agen pions tel pions ben je suis un pion
en fait c'est bien du coup ou pas chez
ba ba du coup il ya un peu de tout quoi
il ya des étoiles il ya des couronnes et
des diamants fille un pion quoi alors
d'un guide suis en cours mais je voulais
trop venir vous suivrez ba écoute
ben écoute au vaincu peut nous suivre on
va commenter autre chose sera très
intéressant parce que c'est une bonne
après midi ensemble puis et voilà donc
chaque jour pendant les candidats on va
quand même faire le taf divertir et puis
donc du coup on va essayer de sortir
plein de trucs sur bitstream web on
verra aussi d'en discuter avec l'élite
si vous avez des idées du coup voilà des
parties pédagogique des trucs ne fera qu
on trouve pas mal de concept pour façon
nous y est pas toujours faire la même
chose sinon on va faire chier très
concrètement et voilà du coup lors pas
de tourner en direct à suivre leurs pas
de parti d'actu tout ça on oublie
bon on peut créer là dessus dans les
airs il a évidemment avant l'actuelle
actuel puis là on est à la pointe de
l'actuelle ariane jacky monde pourquoi
je cite juste eu tôt fait ce qui m'a mis
de youtube le rapport bas ils bossent à
la fidh en fait ni un poste où je sens
c'est lui qui était en charge de tout ça
et directeur des rallyes qui prenait les
décisions finales qui a imposé que l'on
ait lieu et c'est donc surtout sur lui
[Musique]
que je déverse la responsabilité envers
il n'a sûrement d'autres je connais pas
tous les gens qui travaillent mais lui
tu es vraiment charge ce truc et il a
pris les mauvaises décisions et on
espère qu'ils en assument les
conséquences mais après ça
non non non non bâle où il a tout fait
pour sauver l'outil qu'il a pris la
bonne décision c'est pas de chance mais
lyon reste au sol il faut pas prévoir
donc voilà peut-être une prime qui
devrait toucher une prime pour ça non
mais c'est ça le discours c'est là bas
nous on a tout bien faire regarder
d'alerté donc c'était bien personnes
étaient affectées du corona les joueurs
étaient complètement sécurité ça a été
parfait ce qu'on a fait vraiment pas de
chance ces abrutis ont cloué les avions
au sol bon bah alors là devant le fait
accompli on ne pouvait rien faire et on
n'a pas pu sauver le cycle d'hommage à
messaâd le discours est non mais c'est
clairement ça qu'elle est l'info dont
robin candidat soit il n'y a plus non
plus c'est pas prévu en mai mais bon on
y sert à table veut les jouer dans un
deuxième temps c'est dégueulasse qui les
jouent pas vu ce qui s'est passé là et
enfin c'est c'est très très spécial mais
là maintenant quoi que tu fasses son
s'il ya quelque chose qui frappe c'est
soit annuler ce qui a été fait donc fi z
maxime et dépôts qui sont des tapas et
ronde
c'est complètement injuste soit tu
gardes le classement actuel turin tegra
job of qui jouera pas mêmes
circonstances
donc c'est aussi injuste mais soit tu
perds contre 3 comme ça bien c'est
injuste cuisine radjabov fils et tous
les mecs étaient orphelins mais qui
n'ont pas pu défendre leur chance
une gentille ont tous dit gré mais bon
vous pas de 49 ans qui n'était pas non
plus au top et c est donc quoique tu
dessines tuku l'aise des gens mais là il
ya plus de solutions enfin c'était
c'était facile de léser personne en
décalant les candidats ça a été la
décision responsable ça at-elle tout
facile donc surtout pas donc on joue on
sauve le cycle et et on fait ça voilà
c'est incroyable
c'est juste incroyable en fait maxime
ici c'est quoi ce cloud se fait en gros
et les joueurs les arbitres les
officiels soient peuvent pas rentrer
chez eux à la fin du que les avions sont
cloués au sol enfin cette fille ni
vraiment vendredi soir est donc là il
peut encore rentré aujourd'hui c'est
demain sauf peut-être un peu demain oui
c'est demain soir
donc là ils ont un jour et demi pour
pour rentrer comme ils peuvent
et si son camp en russie samedi bal à il
va jusqu'à on sait pas quand fin avant
de rentrer à pied ou je ne sais pas mais
ce qu'il ya de débile c'est que la même
en ayant plus de précisions aujourd'hui
je pense que tout ne va pas rentrer et
faut rappeler qu'il ya toujours ce genre
de repos tu auras tu apprécies ronde
c'était aussi ridicule mais au moins les
gens rentrés chez eux la crainte avec
quatre jours que trois vols je constate
à y arriver là bon une journée d' mines
passe sur tf1 bien visibles ne sais pas
expliquer une annulation quoi elle sans
compter que tu prends le second truc à
dire ce qu'ils sont pas moscou sert
comme ce coup je pense ça peut aller
dans un gros os ville et 4-1 bourget
répond ça se passe
le problème c'est que tu vas devoir
prendre le premier vol à la con j'aurais
khater un bourg istanbul ou je sais pas
quoi et tu vas devoir re galères et de
là bas mais j'ai en fait pas ton
meilleur choix tu pensé quitter la
russie vite mais s'avère que tout
augmente aussi tété chance de tomber
malades infectés ta famille de croise
des gens elle le sait non mais c'est
favre je sais pas si c'est un truc de
fou
c'est un truc de fou il sembla de libre
ils ne peuvent pas rentrer chez eux
seront encore dead le ratage c'est très
très froid c'est très bon
bon bref voilà mon nom mais la réponse
est pas comment ils vont prendre
est ce que savait ce qu'on pense maxime
on est plus petit noël
je vais vite fait à droite ça ils
allaient se grouiller décédé
schopenhauer
voilà c'est tout ce que je sais normal
quand nous y sommes déçus nantes de
ouais bon ça je peux le temps d'une
bombe enfin oui bah sûrement mais bon
après maxime il était très philosophe
cette histoire il savait que ça pouvait
arriver a dit moment il savait que ça
pouvait arriver il était là il joua les
parties vous n'êtes pas d'état d'âme il
est en mission et lui va bien gérer tout
ça la bonne attitude vraiment il a
vraiment une excellente attitude et mais
chapeau à lui un chapeau à lui c'est
bien ce qu'il a fait je verrai du coup à
wil ans mais bon d'après ce qu'ils ont
signés comme contre hama lors quelles
valeurs je leur dis que ça ou quoi c'est
les résultats sont acquis
donc en gros pour maxime pour l'instant
le cirque en attendant en tant que lead
à un coleader donc pas de quoi être si
déçu que ça non plus à la fin mai oui
après ça peut changer la dynamique genre
kawana pourra revenir bain bien
meilleure forme sachant qu aux caisses
prépare à fond ils achèteront il faut
gagner un tournoi sur cette fronde en
scorant beaucoup il y aura d'autres
dispositions très changera la dynamique
du tournant avec ses terrains ça c'est
sûr mais bon après comme je dis est ce
qu'on reprendra le temps comme il est là
kindo radjabov ce que certains joueurs
vont demander à faire annuler ce qui
s'est passé je sais pas là on peut
émettre plein de suppositions j'ai
aucune idée je sais pas donc le contrat
qu'ils ont signé ce que ça vaut si tu
peux s'il ya des failles des
personnellement je suis digne bon je
sais qu'il est gentil après un mais je
pense que les sept ronds la rejouer je
vais revoir coiffe un geste m'a fait
faire deux mois de quarantaine tu m'as
fait de faire partie de partir de chez
moi alors que une épidémie très grave
il n'habite pas très loin du du wan
enfin tu m'as fait venir des places et
tu as fait garder deux semaines à moscou
de semaine avec hatem ben arfa c'est que
tu vas rêve tourne au milieu tu me faire
revenir alors que j'ai deux points et
demi pas juste ça
ouais bah ouais non mais enfin où est un
plongeur en tant que la france a
vraiment pété un tournant et en ce qui
concerne ou en gare ou ici ça peut il
peut tirer les marrons du feu
parce qu'évidemment de façon il y en a
rien à [ __ ] il va revenir pour vous et
cette ronde
voilà tout est possible oui on n'est pas
largués mais peut-être ce sera 14 rondes
d'être qu'alimente aurait intégré du raj
adoptent qui on tire au sort le grand
jeu c'est par un bel homme non ils ont
tellement été au dessus en terme d'
incompétence que maintenant je me tend
un atout ait son âme et honnêtement je
vois vraiment pas de bonne solution quoi
vraiment pas d'ombré au site
ils peuvent aussi de faire un truc à la
saint-louis ste feyre un tournoi où il
mène une meilleure métrage a pas fait
magnus et sûrs décide de champion du
monde sur un tournant avec dix joueurs
maintenant montagneuse de refuser oui
mais si tu sors pas nous le cycle aller
pour sauver le cycle parce que du coup
on fait valoir aussi qui trouve de
l'argent pour leurs matches après
et quel argent et machin c'est spécial
un nom mais je pense c'est ça qui veut
sauver dans le cycle qu'ils avaient dû
trouver à refourguer le tournage sait
plus où là on a les émirats arabes unis
aux émirats et que fait je suis coup ça
va changer savent plus comment faire ils
sont fauchés cette simple est le symbole
du tweak c'était juste un truc financier
sûrement je suis quasiment sûr que c'est
ça on sait pas mais non je sais je sais
ce que tu annules tout est un cycle
important
je dois vraiment avoir lieu en décembre
c'est pas si l'on aux émirats arabes
unis durant un autre wild card mais le
truc c'est que c'est pas les candidats
aux émirats c'est le match pour le titre
donc c'était le vainqueur des candidats
qu'ils vont me rejoindre magnus vrai
pourquoi ne pas faire des parties temps
a simplement sur internet à cause de la
triche le monsieur luca c'est toujours
pareil
mais bon moi je pense que c'est vraiment
pas en faveur de maxime après ce report
personnellement non parce que là en fait
vu la dynamique
je le sentais bien gagner quoi bateau je
te disais aujourd'hui qu'on le carnage
aurait pris peur non mais non c'est
confiant alors que caruana dans un état
de forme à fond qui tout frais tu te
fais ce qu et contador en jaune fait tu
peux te faire secouer par ding qui peut
revenir avec d'autres intentions
parce que là on fait enchaîner noir
caruana digue acquarone actes et pas
très en forme et ding qui était qui et l
ombre de dingila fc marketing que tu vas
voir en face le soleil ging du peu
d'offres donc dangereux est ok great uk
on sait qu'il a du mal à faire les
tournois de l'année recommence balaye
recommencer on sait que gary kurtz un
mec qui a besoin d'être chaud dans les
premières rondes donc il suffit qu'ils
battent avec celle qu avec les noirs et
il est là on fait et touques donc tu
relances quand même pas mal de mecs
après en ce qui concerne les peaux je
sais pas je pense que pour lui ça change
pas grand chose
on sait pas il aurait pu regagner
reperdre n'est plus un peu la roulette
russe couche-tard est à la roulette
russe
à mon avis ça pour lui ça change pas
grand chose non je pense quand même
utile de tutos compense comme il est
malade qui cotait dans la corona ou quoi
se doit leur assurer de sopot ce qui se
passe à m
c'est un joueur qui attrape le corona
machin c'est encore une autre histoire
at&t but aurait pu faire sur internet il
suffisait de mettre un représentant de
la fidh pour chaque voir et voilà c'est
réglé oui il faut c'est compliqué à
faire tu fais quoi si la connexion saute
enfin il ya plein de problèmes qua non
mais juste fois la porte et c'est pas
dur en fait c'est assez simple tueur
porte tu attends que le monde aille
mieux
on sait pas qu'en fait on verra quand tu
auras plus de confinement partout des
tons ageas cochon corona ben oui ça
c'est en fait les échecs c'est du loisir
quoi quelques parties à diffuser plus
importante de la santé des gens en
premier lieu lors à l'économie a sur lui
et en a plein de trucs très très très
important mais on croit dans un second
temps à refaire des matchs de foot des
échecs des choses comme ça
et donc bon on fera un autre jour mbhele
semi premier du smi tournoi c'est bon le
cycle est sauvé il peut affronter un
smicard la scène sinon tu peux annuler
le cycle de 2020 pour le championnat du
monde tu peux aussi un cycle aux normes
cik leblanc est sûrs mais turbulent 2020
caruana qui rejoint notre stand
si les décisions façon c'est comme le
foot en fait je veux dire on fait quoi
avec le championnat c'était une
discussion enfin le foot au rugby tout
ce que tu as mais pour le foot il ya
plusieurs options se sont fait une année
blanche si on frise le classement prend
le classement tel qu'il est maintenant
les mecs sont ligue 2 de pretty les fait
monter
tu joues à 22 l'an prochain il ya plein
de discussion chacun qui est chiant mais
ça ne sera jamais un truc comme non mais
je suis d'accord avec je sais plus qui a
écrit ça dans le chat mais ça ça peut en
réalité être une décision femmes
candidats blancs et on reprend caruana
parce que ça il ya deux ans est numéro 1
willow quand même maillot numéro deux
mondial sur le sol bizarre je sais pas
j'ai pas de nom mais tu as bizarrement
même si c'est dès que pour maxime là
pour la peine et pour les peaux pour les
deux c'est vraiment dégueu et pour les
autres aussi d'ailleurs mais c'est tout
les mecs qui étaient selon sylvain qui
était 3e le coup de coude mais mais
quelque part c'est une décision qu'il ça
laisse tout le monde et en même temps ça
laisse personne sur ce que je veux dire
c'est comme le tournant en soie dorée
c'est peut-être la décision là la pire
est la moins pire en même temps je sais
pas mais c'est une décision bizarrement
une décision qui peut être considéré que
je prendrais pas si tôt mon truc mais
façon maintenant ils sont mis dans la
merde et quoi qu'ils fassent ils vont
les y du où il pas qu'une personne a
dans tous les cas si tu reprends les
statuts landing radjabov caruana au bas
mot
si tu reprends pas qui fait la décision
caruana tu laisse quand même ces mecs là
mais dans l'esprit comme les candidats
on n'est pas content et tu fais un peu
comme les autres et tu fais comme si
rien n'avait existé
es tu là elle est un peu tout le monde
mais à moindre comment dire en fait tu
laisses tout le monde mais amont et ce
tout le monde autant alors que des
bombes tuent favorise graves terrorisme
et de favoriser grave caruana
sinon ou alors tu as l'autre solution
mais qui prendront jamais mais qui est
peut-être finalement la meilleure pour
moi c'est une à 200 litres an à 2 0 et
sûrs et invite radjabov oui tu peux
faire ça aussi mais là du coup tu l'aise
principalement maxime les niveaux maxima
2 me tue le laisse
oui oui mais maxime il devrait juste pas
y être
donc tu le laisses il a fait un bon
début de tournoi mais d'un autre part
est disons qu'il a gagné sa place au
candidat grâce à vous sont demandées du
tournoi quoi tu peux prendre ça avec
philosophie et tu n'as tu laisses n'est
peau du cou non mais quoi qu'il en soit
les yeux ou non ils se sont mis dans une
situation où c'est comme ça ou alors tu
veux tu finis achi foulée mais bon là
bas il est bon est le chiffon mise
sarrecave à quelques choses infâmes bas
bonnes saveurs bout d'un moment est-ce
que tu as droit de prendre un champion
tu vas te représenter toi maintenant
suis très présente toi même et à sang le
puits par contre oui bah non c'est
papier qui est aussi irene a déjà signé
un mec qui fait puis c'était
éliminatoires élimination directe coup
illégal
pire que je veux la grogne là pendant la
remise
ils ont commencé il faut le finir dans
trois mois éventuellement y met dans
trois mois dans quel monde tu joues dans
des conditions correctes et dans quel
monde on as qu'il n'y a pas des pays
encore en quarantaine ce que les
frontières sont réouverts enfin là en
fait on ne sait pas on va en fait tout
le monde je sais pas si vous réalisez on
se dit dont nous à se confiner dans six
semaines on ressort en reprenant
évidemment toute cette nouvelle annonce
sera pas le cas ce ne sera pas le monde
d'avant c'est c'est spécial et moi grand
sahara et où je vais à colmar
je vais à colmar nar mais oui ça va pas
être le vent d'avant donc en fait oui
pas si vous pensez que le monde avant
évidemment on vous dit oui bon bourgeois
en trois mois trois maires d'autres que
la fiq crozier d'ailleurs mais bon vous
aura des surprises
contractuellement si quelqu'un refuse de
continuer il est exclu du prochain signe
à méditer wilfart belle serait ce que
ton pays
non mais non en plus il faut voir c'est
que la russie il commença à confiner
faire à confiner il commence à faire une
semaine fériée donc là c'est encore un
autre concept c'est pas confiner ces
faits c'est arié donc tôt ou tu vas le
resto du coin mais bon peu importe mais
un bon c'est férié mais ça commence à
être fériés à partir de samedi c'est à
dire que ça nous place
le 28 mars nous suprendre huit semaines
qui est le truc quand même minimum un
peu dans tous les pays qu'on voit ça te
ramène quand même déjà rien que le
confinement la barre à fin juin afin
notamment à l' abri mais ferme en
vigueur début juin new way fait début
juin des méchants ça travaille à début
juin mais ça ce sera en russie qui te
dit qu'en france on sera pas de nouveau
à confiner à avant après le thé
confinement le machin faf états unis je
sais pas si ils n'en ratent rappelé
complet ils ont fait leur spring break
donc là on s'expose non c'est compliqué
c'est complet c'est cela m'étonnerait
que dans trois mois tu puisses défi bon
quand tu réorganise la forêt 6 par
rapport à prévoir à prévenir les joueurs
ça se fait par en deux jours j'imagine
d'art organisé ça habille deuxième truc
les joueurs sont assez décontracté grant
l'histoire des trucs normalement ils
sont guéris oui bailly juste comme ça
moi je pense sera pas lui non plus et
manchester mais soit dit au passage si
jamais céder confiner la sinne que fils
qui a fait signer des contrats et que
ses joueurs qu'ils balancent des
millions choisira non je te libères qui
va jouer ces candidats ou d'autres c'est
trop ou pas c'est à 10 annoncée
c'est un vrai problème or gris saison
blanc je suis rincé puisse réintégration
radjabov mais moi je trouve ça trop
dégueu prend maxime de faire ça donc je
sais pas franchement mais il ya ils sont
mis tout seul dans la mer est chaude et
qu'il décide d'annuler ayez by côté une
crise sanitaire mondiale on verra quand
ce sera fini on prend la décision à ce
moment là on leur bon voilà ça a été
comme ça et là bon bah tu les aimes
aucun joueur en particulier
c'était justement car sur ce que dit sur
ce que dit simple être femme est ce que
tu te coupe mais c'est vrai qu'il dit
les joueurs ont leur part de
responsabilité il aurait fait preuve de
solidarité toute cette mascarade n'avait
pas eu lieu et c'est vrai que la cp tu
vas le fait qu'il ait pas de syndicats
de joueurs d'échecs ou en tout cas deux
groupes de joueurs d'échecs
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
d'aussi à méditer parce qu'au tennis
je rugby tu as 8 bits à la probable
d'aller jouer dans un syndicalisme en
représentant ils sont un poids là les
joueurs n'ont aucun poids et il n'y a
pas de solidarité entre les joueurs quoi
alors que la cp mais à l'association des
joueurs d'échecs professionnels demander
quand même le report chan signalé des
candidats mais elle doit servir dans le
groupe
tout à fait d'ailleurs les crises n'a
écrit aujourd'hui il est très énervé
oui oui mais j'espère que les joueurs
aussi ces fraudeurs c'est quelque chose
quand même je trouve assez pertinent ne
pas tout mettre quand même sur la fidh
même si sur les joueurs qui souvent
viennent juste prendre le chèque
tout au long de l'année quoi voilà bon
sens vraiment pensé principal --en la
fidh commune oui mais les joueurs pense
pas non plus forcément très profondément
au sport tout au long de l'année qua non
mais bon après si la fille de leur fait
peur à dire oui si tu joues pas tu
joueras pas avant deux ans de truc
machin tu dégages du prochain cycle ça
peut te faire peur
je te dis oui bon le corps n'a peut-être
ça va aller jean couty croix et t'as pas
le recul nécessaire combien décidé après
j'ai pas enlever son patron décide de
traçabilité mais ok peut-être un décor
sans faute à la file comme un bassin qui
après il faut aussi voir que pour
certains à ils ont claqué une fortune en
ce moment donc c'est arrêter ces
financiers rend dangereux rassure toi
si t'as pas un travail avec 4 0 par mois
derrière ton salaire et qui sont
beaucoup plus 5 3 donc c'est gerald les
échecs ça je quand même est une
discipline qui rapportent plus d'argent
qu'on ne peut le penser de l'extérieur
j'imagine et les seconds ans et pas
assez pas ça qui va les faire mourir de
faim qua non la plupart les ont ils ont
des sponsors en plus les choses comme ça
non mais bien sûr c'est vrai que c'est
quand même point soulevé que c'est vrai
que tu ça va maintenant pour eux cette
année en plus pour les joueurs pros
d'échec bâton à son abus les gens ok
moins moi qui suis pas dans ce cirque là
tu vois j'ai plein de billets d'avion je
pense qu'on s'envoler des trucs comme ça
il n'y a pas les olympiades les
pastillas pas ça ça va être un peu
chiant mais bon c'est la vie après tu
vois les échecs quand on a la chance
aussi de pouvoir faire les trucs à
distance de poura sur internet je peux
commenter
on n'est pas les plus à plaindre tu as
des gens cool et commerces sont fermés
0-0 et qu en plus des employés ou des
gens qui ont parlé des gens qui sont
hôtesses de caisse au supermarché ou
quoi et qui doit va être obligé d'aller
travailler tous les jours parce que
c'est un travail essentiel et qui
prennent qui mettent leur vie en danger
ils sont enfin payer deux mois deux
secondes ans je pense que c'est pas ça
va mais souama diagonale il fait
ressemble au premier tour des
municipales
va-t-il faire ou pas oui ou événements
fallait pas faire
et c'est vrai que ça ressemble à ça en
fait c'est aussi grotesques karaté
municipal au mieux c'est bizarre que
chacun fasse une connerie à son échelle
presque mvele un sponsor je crois qu'il
a un mécène au maximum le patient puisse
assurer ses sponsors mécènes à lui
demander mais les deux peut-être aussi
je sais pas pas fait il à sa chemise ou
la logique on s'appelle son truc
courrier international rien ouais donc
ça c'est ce qu'on entend mais il aurait
dû remettre un colis et kimi scène de
ces derniers temps mais les augures
gilou coup je sais pas comment ça marche
un bon pour demander aux photos mais il
a une aide quoi bon je remets liens de
l'aréna qui commence en 13 minutes on va
on va commenter des parties de haut
niveau aujourd'hui et ils sont connus du
joug du goût a non on commente non parce
que je te vois inscrit à mes cheveux
pâles des anciens sinon je je je je fais
porter le tournoi donc on jouera la
vague jours et la première conduite est
appelé à porter
je me suis juste mis là pour les gens ne
voit quoi
donc les haricots verts bonduelle comme
sponsor pour mv elles m'ont dit c'est
une arène un vrai scénario et des petits
poulets poulet quoi duc comme un léger
auxerre à l'époque je serai beaucoup
qu'il un gros truc d'ucla au 1001 trucs
quoi s'est longtemps que j'ai pas mangé
tuque ouest souffle c'est pas mal partie
des petites triables de ton dos ioukos
comme un fouet
c'est une bonne idée ça tient qui des
recettes tu fais du samouraï du thon
c'est pas mal on sent aussi surtout que
j'en ai acheté du st morêt ben super à
cotton toiles huiles dans mon fiston est
lui en fin de journée avec sa ballade tu
vas te régaler les échos plus des
festins christian crohem quoi ouais j'ai
dû du thon de marc de maar que monoprix
je crois donc mes marques de base ok ça
c'est un peu le hip hop us enfin c'est
vrai et du poids et du coup j'ai quoi
j'ai ça donc j'ai le saint moret donc de
marc st moret et ben j'aurais du pinsan
marque en fait t'as du pain quoique de
marque casino peut-être qui arrivera ça
va marque casino qui s'enfonce bah c'est
pas casino saveurs quoi ces casinos
basique
donc ça va annoncer bollaërt le porte
parole du kremlin donc c'est un peu la
sib et n'diaye russe comme dimitri
peskov qui a déclaré au sujet de la
possibilité de mettre en place un état
d'urgence qui était inutile dans la
mesure ne vont pas d'épidémie alethia
papymik normes et donc du fait fériés
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant mais
j'adore en fait leur concept de fer
fériés voilà on va pas garder ta et ses
pourcentages convoi pourrait paraître le
tournoi il ya pas d de lannion jours
ouais mais bien d'un epide
mais il n'y a pas d'épidémie a pas
d'état d'urgence pourquoi tu arrêtes jeu
comprendra en fait
c'est bizarre sur lifetime qui dit c'est
vrai il a vraiment dit ça ce matin
ah oui mais pourquoi tu arrives à 1 mais
là je vous redonne le ballon mais en
fait c'est sûr qu'elle sur quels
critères en fait tu arrêtes mais
peut-être ça joue à tanger regrette et
on ou trois ans ça joue pas non mais la
maxime est d'ailleurs je sai il va
rentrer par amsterdam avec les autres
joueurs ils ont trouvé souple en lâchant
son fils déchets guerric aux sabots
staragora donc les habitants ici dit le
mec est fou cette déclaration est
incompréhensible surtout après celle de
poutine mais bon tu me les enlever leurs
six bateaux ya eu c'est la même chose au
niveau à quoi bon mais je sais pas ce
qu'ils vont faire à la fin de la semaine
fériée carnaval carnaval série qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas passé à cause du risque
d'être mal année parce que les joueurs
risquent de ne pas pouvoir rentrer chez
eux oui mais c'est quoi la différence
avec le début du tournoi où les pays ont
été mis en quarantaine
je vous renvoie en fait il risqué il y
avait des flammes
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent pas rentrer
chez eux non mais en plus tu peux genre
d'origine vol pâte affrété un jet à luz
tu sors de trucs humains jets 24 une
solution c'était vraiment un bon soir
était de la merde aussi mais on puisse
voir kovic également un proche de
poutine
donc si tesla friend connect comme ça
lui le droit de voler et tu leur fais un
jet tu es un jet privé tutu j'ai pas
d'atouts et j'arrive à chasser les vols
réguliers vers les pays étrangers qui
sont stoppés exactement battu fait un
vol non régulés jacques brillet régulier
pas régulé il regarde il est payé plus
d'ailleurs y est partie la disparue
était là a enfin il est à amsterdam déjà
donc il aurait dans tous les cas pu leur
affrété un avion diagonale
il dit il rentre à amsterdam en jet
privé midas des mises à disposition par
le gouvernement russe
si c'est vrai quoi en tout cas je sais
qu'ils rentrent amsterdam oui c'est
possible
travaux avec sa touche ighirri
complètement bloquée à faire que des
nuls coiffe pardon mais en plus les pays
boos pas un billet pas de confinement le
sens pour ça peut-être qu'ils peuvent le
faire je sais pas s il me semblait que
les pays boos voulait faire la limite et
collectivement ça me projette autre
chose des soirées nul qu'ils allaient
rendre et serait beau quand elle fait
sourit fille que des nuls les condyles
biden au début quand je te haïr ont été
moins longue leçon table ronde - la
grèce doit même pas lieu lot
et que penser de cette solution tu frise
le cassant et cardigans actuelle tu
transformes ça en grand prix puis fait
un autre tour nokia invite que les
candidats puissent radjabov sur trois
autres grands prix oui mais en fait tu
vas tu vas jamais vieillir la paf où il
veut et il a opté vouloir gagner quatre
tournois des candidats comme ce serait
beau quoi et en plus quand tu fais un
grand prix à notre avis a atteint 4 ils
vont trouver bon tu viens avec 5 go qui
de toute façon ne méritait pas sa
wild-card tu reprends le débat sur sa
aussi bref
et puis voilà que matt et d'ailleurs ça
c'est une solution comme enfin trois des
candidats ont dégagé avec c'est une
courbe et un job mais ça peut être ça la
meilleure solution en réalité et
recommencer de zéro il bon de toute
façon tu votes
c'était dernier du classement voilà et
j'ai même pas si le prendre estivale il
pourrait être héros a bien oui je sauve
le psy que je laisse ma place
ils sont dans mon cas
masterclass par guy tous les plans de
nul est beaucoup j'ordonne il est ok
pour virer que c'est une cause votre
dans notre oeil l'idée qu on a trouvé la
cua ses marques et le report bas parce
que ça joue pas médicis ce qu'est le
tour a été reporté en fête du goût va
reportent leurs portes à dakar mais par
contre à la reine nasa les arcanes de
pas de report ont la même avance et sûrs
que ce soit 14 heures 12 heures 30
chansons à 10 arrêts là on les fera qu'à
l'heure du coup de 12h30 12h en être à
12h15 fait rentrer les deux examinateurs
legrand qui qu'un ps il y avait du coup
dessus de la psyché si on va faire des
arts ina des de la pédagogie
comment 10 ajustements à corps plein de
trucs ce soit ici mais surtout sur
bitstream
et donc si vous avez des idées justement
là c'est sérieux dites nous parce que il
y aura pas de parti a suivi aura pas de
tournoi il y aura pas d'actu échec
spécialement on va l'a créée donc qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour pas s'ennuyer pas
très positif et faire des trucs sympas
et marron joueurs football manager on
peut faire ça un peu beauf manager on
peut faire du tft on peut faire des
échecs des chèques à 4 du du bugue house
des rois de la montagne que je compte
des communautés pédagogie revolver plein
de trucs trop les nouveaux chais pas
vous pouvez soumettre des trucs c'est
pas mal ouais si vous avez des idées
c'est plutôt bien comme ça on trouve des
roquettes ligue oui non mais enfin ça
peut être n'importe quel jeu droit de
belote bien évidemment ça c'est
d'ailleurs je joue déjà le fait des
petites soirées belote avec matt
elle joue très très bien mais c'est un
bon joueur maintenant on a longtemps
parlé de théories d'annonce de machin a
mis au point un truc très bien on a
gagné beaucoup de tournois montpellier
ou quoi quand on joue ensemble et bon
championnat de france parce que je crois
à m'associer à qu à l occasion ou au
jour avec rémy mon pote aussi n'importe
quoi fin mai quand et aux bons joueurs
de belote elle son niveau c'est ces
puits appartiennent à
cette carte appartient cette donne mais
tu vois j'ai fait un petit fichier
j'ai acheté cinq livres de belote jeux
pour aller chercher voulu montrer où
j'ai lu j'ai étudié à fond là j'ai fait
un compte rendu
j'avais un fichier excel afin de ward
plus tôt où je fais un peu tous les
systèmes des annonces possibles des
petites modifications je pense
intéressante a testé plein de trucs on
invite l eau qui est restée très heureux
d'avoir montre nous sommes vous voulez
chercher j'ai cherché les mots j'arrive
quand même fait dans l'aréna va
peut-être qu'il va venir 1 pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas retrouver mes veines dans
l'aréna avec les frais seraient la
coiffe ou quatre par enel va commencer
partie pédagogique en trombe rsa on va
sur pédagogie fier 1 on va on va aussi
voir on va aussi voir ce que tu as comme
organismes vont peut-être pas réalisé
des petits heaven sent pas nous écouter
non ça c'est une c'est la méthode pour
pour bien contré des fois tu dis je
contre jeu contre pas je sais pas je le
sens le sens pas balle ait donne méthode
mathématique attention la méthode
méthode 82 that's what else
donc ça c'est système d'annoncés à 81,2
à stoke s'est pas de 80 petit jeu mais
l'autre contrer le jeu de la carte à lui
très intéressant josé orsatelli ont
sûrement fait que le corps ait fait les
trucs comme ça
le monde dédouane de vie ce qui se passe
les annonces que c'était ce qu'ils ont
dit ce qu'ils ont fait a été dit oui ça
c'est un meilleur ou améliorer sa sortie
n'est pas cette donne très mal joué
oui il a des fossés deux carreaux rien
voir rien navarra incroyable je n'ai
jamais vu ça c'est si vous causez
l'alsace sait-il que le valais plus fera
à tous alors tu joues comme ça c'est une
question que je me pose quoi s'est il a
peu joué
voilà et wade arrive qu'ils n'ont lu
beaucoup trop amateur comment je
conseille mais les quatre là il était
bien donc loser satellite cool
il a écrit deux lots x et y s'appelle
l'autre d'envoyer un mail il m'a répondu
ou quoi il était très heureux mais c'est
déjà reçu le mail oui incroyable encore
un abruti qui l'écrit je n'en peux plus
qua non je salue lui suggéra des trucs
louis auduc hot stuff de très heureux
quand je peux rester j'ai déjà analysé
ça il ya 17 ans sûrement petit carnet
j'ai déjà tout réfuté quoi analyse quoi
et appelle la donc voilà j'ai fait tout
ça et du coup j'ai faim je fais un
contrôle du coup je pense qu'à des flat
dans tous les domaines broyé canne à
swing vlad mais oui delà des gens qui
savent être un peu comme ça tu aurais je
le disais un truc est ce que le
professeur raout alpha molo
c'est pas un genre de vlad de la
médecine quoi bon un peu non mais elle
est lui beaucoup plus petit
comment vous n'avez pas compris que se
cacher soit ton traitement n'appartient
pas ce virus mais y croit vraiment à son
truc en aucun cas et je pense à un
joueur de l'aj moi je suis pas compétent
donc pas m'avancer la demande donne des
conseils aux gens ou quoi mario revient
à dire trahi y croit à fond il a
démissionné conseil de chez pas quoi
parce que les mecs les coûts de paul
sont vraiment cons non mais il y croit à
un jeu d'erreurs que tu fais pas ça sur
un coup de tête comme ça tu énervé ou le
fameux buzz
je le savais je lis de toucher toujours
en sucres lents vrai niveau vraiment
content de ce professeur yves latvala
rencontre of the knee entre quoi tu sais
dans mon domaine aussi c'est vraiment
des coups je votre compte leurs droits
or voilà quoi
[Musique]
c'est un genre de gambie ben quoi
améliorer il a retardé ces cinq très mal
je serai heureux ah bon on commente
cette partie faucon la gaillarde heures
j'ai perdu une partie sur des connexions
j'étais dégoûté bon alors on a été en
fait à l'aise pendant pendant une demi
heure on est reparti sur les échecs mon
famille nouvel outil aujourd'hui là il
prend l'avion et sur les notes des
joueurs du coup alain bazot il a misé
roi tu t'obstines as tu étais vraiment
fait ce que tu as été un vrai par le
doute et comme je connais moi c'est
l'autre mais il a mis il a mis 10 au
cours de laquelle j'espère mais je passe
il a mis d'autres notent aussi le mix
homme et je les regardais ce que le
cours là tu veux lui mais triste en
allant très fort tu as laissé le tournoi
solange et les candidats y x ou c'est
bon quoi je me place infâme bas va te
laver la tête partout tu as les
fonctions de tréteaux qui découpe
l'échiquier sont une partie par coups là
il vient me nuire regarde il nuit à mon
action quoi ben ok je vais madame je
protège mon fou et je vais quand même le
faire avancer c'est pas possible il n'ya
toutes mes pièces mon femmes
je suis là mais je n'ose pas trop parler
pendant tes parties que disait j'aime
pas je compte ba oui non mais je vais à
2 contre quelqu'un de tout seul c'est
pas cool alors qu'on nous vend du vin
cerveau qu on s'affaiblit bon pourquoi
pas mais non mais sinon c'est pas cool
non franchement l'a jamais fait on ne
fera jamais assez petit donc j'ai même
pas envie de faire une expression de
visage ou de trop suivre il a été quand
même très heureux de la case 3 de tout
ce à quoi on se bat encore fait c'est
pas forcément les positions grâce à ça
commence quand je ne pense pas mixer ya
plus a pu annuler et reporter il ne
pensait pas va voir la vidéo youtube
midstream si tu veux et la du groupe une
arena pour les faits pour les oreilles
pour monde
je suis un cas révèle femme oui du
bordeaux stick moi il est trop haut sur
l'échiquier je trouve un teint qui
serait millions à 5
vive le shass et sous cavalière rebondi
quoi way we partout où il va il saute il
est heureux quoi est heureux c'est
génial à colmar il revient pas je vais à
colmar c'est fantastique
annulez ou reportez monde mick bombe a
reporté mais on sait pas où tout peut se
passer comme ouais ouais moi écouter
avant son option on y va être passé mon
fab four chaud ce gars face à l'ircam et
dangereux et joue pas mal moi je connais
depuis longtemps autre club de lyon
ensemble des petits coups c'est un
lyonnais
ouais alors maintenant beïda il y
plusieurs familles qui demandent est-ce
qu'on va arrêter la reine au bout de 45
minutes et finir demain c'est une option
j'aime pas trop ce que j'ai fait les
derniers coups j'ai pas été âgé pas été
brillantissime montfavet je vais très
brillant du tout en fait à une très
bonne position je les pourris battant de
tepa matsa matt l'émission matt note
matt fonce donc du coup oui je vais voir
si ma zoé d'autres notent aussi les
communes auteurs ajoutent aux citoyens
méritent 0 enfin il a eu les héros mais
les mérites nom est d'avis que 0 à ce
tuto null null null une catastrophe
ambulante à défendre ce tournoi des
candidats pour des intérêts financiers
il n'a rien du charisme et finale de la
ligue des champions contre le real
madrid en pire oui ensemble de carlus
pour le coup c'est quand même pris un
coup de coude dans la tente
le ramos donc il était affaibli lors que
la prod coup il a peut-être coup de
coude de cris touché d'avoir abandonné 1
je fais n'importe quoi j'ai écouté tes
notes de masoe puis à samaa j'ai envers
ses docs ou que je voulais faire en fait
je vais faire un tour c'est cette es tu
vois non mais j'y adhère fois j'ai
remarqué en fait quand à quelqu'un qui
parle à côté c'est impossible de jouer
snapple
si tu parle pas de la partie c'est ça
absolument impossible
ça me faire perdre des points quoi parle
t on au rebus calcul n'importe quoi
c'est vraiment possible de faire ne
cherche pas d'excusés web c'est quand tu
commences ta partie en fait ça va tu
peux parler ça va parce que tu parles de
tes idées quand tu parle d'autre chose
c'est très compliqué bon c'est pas grave
dans l'autre côté surtout j'étais
tellement gagnant plan porte un nom bien
jouer laurent
sauver ce qui peut l'être mais bon ok ça
peut-être
ah non ça va pas marcher pas de chance
j'étais pas loin de l'arnaqué j'étais
pas loin de l'arnaqué montfavet il
aurait pas eu cet intermédiaire c'était
bon c'est bien joué ça à ma foi car mais
à deux secondes par coup en plus bon pas
bon on regarde un peu l'aréna du coup
fabre vas-y vas-y 1
je suis là bien sûr on commence parti
alors par floby wef est comment sont ils
sont en fin de partie les gars donc faut
commencer par les gars qui sont en bas
au québec on sûr que tu veux on vient on
regarde ils font quoi alors datchy
bouzouk donc ça c'est une expression du
capitaine haddock
entre ballades astra je suis pas un peu
bizarrement la l'état belge ont mis les
cailles en c3 qui n'appartiennent pas la
case mme mais sinon tu vas pas l'air
d'être nom d'allah de regarder un peu ce
qu'écrit maso non pour les pour les
grands moulins ya plus rien à voir j'ai
juste au pendant la partie je voulais
pas trop suivre mais là je poursuis non
non on n'arrive jamais à faire cet
exploit en fait qu'il y en ait un qui
joue l autre joue pas on ne sait pas ce
qu'ils foutent le mondial mais qui s'est
pas trop collés 100 milles
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire mais on sait
pas non plus en fait ce qui remet tout à
zéro au machin normalement ils doivent
garder les points mais comme je te dis
que je disais si j'en rigole s'ils
prennent des avocats s'il ne s'est pas
dit quand on voit ce qu'on va jouer
c'est une question très compliquée voilà
qui est très surpris ouais y'a plus de
reporter encore un petit stream de beats
à karaj fallait faire ça
sykes qui est vraiment bon ben ça qaf1
votre jeu ouais
nous on est nuls non moi je suis très
ému à toi c'est vraiment une cataracte
mais moi je suis catastrophique aux
siens bachi bouzouk à la rigueur ce que
je fais pas trop mal c'est le biais de
sa cape tout seul le christ à ousse way
mountougoula ps devant un adversaire
plus la reprend pour toi tout ça enfin
j'essaie de contrôler ce que je fais
mais deux sinon j'ai beaucoup de mal
mais les échecs à trois on était bon
aussi
ce 4 qu'on se marche un échec deux
échecs trois échecs jusqu'à 4 offrant
l'occasion que tu es là tu as passé 4
qui éteignait je dois ma de damas de ce
prêtre très chiant c'est son intrication
peut de ce fait là bas mais va faire
quoi émargeant faut 7 6 et 5 6 milliards
de messages par damas cinq à wes et bien
s'attaque à 7 ce qui regarde ça regarde
ses sept fixe va j'aime bien les blancs
- bon après ce qu on y aille je ferai
avantage ou pas a voir je ferais bien
fou des schistes fois-ci d'échangé
puisque tu as on le fout ce cas très
forts ces scientologues
ouais c'est que tu call un tour des cinq
ares 1 mais bon tu vas tu apprendras ses
400 vols acide et blond le temps et qui
te font ces quatre prochains madame 30
tours c'est un dab est pas on s'en va et
puis pour moi c'était en place ouais
cecafa ça peut être fort non bon après
vu préparatoire tour c'est en quoi en
tout cas c'est clairement l'idée j'ai
travaillé défend h 4 mais je sais pas
d'autres il aurait pu au trias la calant
sur l'autre aile et essaie de tourner à
bas coûts d'ici se blinde pas mal joué
j'avais un fou au sein comment il peut
reprendre de la dame mais question ses
décisions cette pétillante arrière ce
pourrait être cool n'est ce pas mal
voilées mais à ce stade de france j'ai
cette île madoff ouais je suis pas
dessus c'est juste beau ouais bon toi
c'est toi non naturel varie vraiment
qu'il soit à tour 17
mais durant les planches france ils
doivent essayer duff où j'aurai même
fait tour g8 idée tour des 5 dans
l'autre pas tout j'évite tour des 5 et
au moins autant j'ai trop bien mais
cette j'aime vraiment pas aller trop
bloquer quoi quelqu'un à venir ici
l'acconage sauveur a pas moins donné un
pion mais bon tu n'atteins dans les
plans il va vraiment jouer au centre à
présent sa seule chance avec la tourache
7 c'est que tu fais ça que les noirs les
blancs vos potes face j'ai cinq jours à
dieu il la police revenir en recettes
via j'ai six minutes peut-être bien du
coup je pense qu'on le veuille à tour un
charme non pour pas prendre courage
saint justin
ok bon il fait le truc normal mais
peut-être pouvoir citoyen que j'ai cinq
sapeurs et aux 5
ils seront deux ils se rendent coup pour
coup la maison mère nana enfermé au 5
mai il a vu n'était fini oui c'est une
partie qui se passait plutôt bien pour
les blancs mais la dame en forme il a
peut-être un peu trop dans est un peu
trop dansé avec saddam adam les 5 donc
j'ai mes gars qui d'isoler le retard ce
colis des machins ce qu'on a new show
radjabov consensus bon bah ce qui se
passe officiellement pour l'instant
c'est que le temps est suspendu donc il
aura y reprendre un de ces jours on sait
pas quand tu te sers mieux et il n'y a
pas d'histoire de radjabov ou pas après
ça c'est juste des six positions qu'on
peut avoir
[Musique]
bah je sais pas moi je crée radjabov
jeffrey déjà un procès à des gens qui
esquisse et qui va pas penser à
s'inscrire mais tu pas encore été
inscrit en fait c'est l'avantagé à rain
a c'est que tu peux tu peux ne ressens
tu veux ouais
donc radjabov oui il peut gueuler les
joueurs qui trouvent le truc pas
équitable peuvent dire oui non mais faut
reprendre à zéro c'est n'importe quoi à
machins là tout peut être envisageable
le disons croissance qui est prévu une
fusion reprennent un accès 4 c'est tout
mais m diq ce sera vraiment comme ça les
blancs
normalement aucune mais la pendule
machin bon complément à l'autoroute ya
un petit rajout de deux secondes aussi
comme c'est qu'elle met sur la table
peut s'infiltrer dans le camp adverse et
bonjour à l'essai g7 jeux d'objets
quatre dames bien des milliers de danois
de bombay avec à 3 portillo se dévoyer
votre congrès devrait y arriver là vous
allez voir tout c'est le cas nous on a
des arénas il y en a plein celui dont je
mets le lien a agi cosmique et si jamais
tu peux pas rejoindre ceux qui ont
rejoint leclerc dix crimes avant je
pense que quelqu'un va mettre le lien
il ya bien quelqu'un qui l'a ce lien bon
voilà c'est ça va être gagné 1 on va
aller voir qu'est-ce qu'on va tous pas
les tiens tout ce qu'ils veulent à
l'ouverture depuis le big il est
dérangeant de scandinaves et que quatre
ans fut jusqu'en mai dans cette voie de
plérin
ça se passe comme ça ça me plaît pour
les blancs jack taylor un autre partie
cela des attaques est y assister
et ça devrait gagner alors viens on va
voir tiens on arrive dès le début du 6
au 9 90 contre paquito fimo 19 qui
dorment fo jeudi 19 mai va se
réveillaient
peut-être aller se faire un café ou un
truc qui va arriver un quart 24 ses cinq
paquito du tac au tac il est là il m'a
quel âge peut-on ouidah calage paquito
qui a frôlé la sortie nakache attaques
lâches que joubert afs est complètement
faisable et d'un epci et soudain c'est
d'ailleurs cette cache
ça donne un sens c'est pas idiot en
faute d'un truc c'est que si tu échanges
les dames je pense qu'il va faire il a
pas fait d'amener un sein des mineurs
pour les north libération des cinq
facilement et là tu as un peu de mal à
sortir le fouet c'est solide
tu l'as déjà joué non mais on me l'a
déjà joué quand j'étais petit je croyais
être aidé à me prendre à moi j'avais 12
ans
si c'est parce qu'un truc mais oui tu
vois se joue assez agréable on pourrait
noir avant le problème ça c'était de la
perte fou aussi les blancs ça va mieux
comment faire ou quoi c'est pas mais là
ça va faire tous qui ton nom bas ici
prix je prends tous les thèmes blanc
fait mais quand dessin qui joue à blanc
genre structure c'est toujours grave
parce que tu as le 2 contre 1 au centre
qui se matérialise exactement depuis le
pion le cas tout va partir il ya ces
deux et ses accès bon il faut trois
chemins séparés
il paraît qu'elle se trouve ce qui est
créé une soupe à laisser vos données
orange peuvent être trop gentil web
apple n'a pas demandé sa démission
timisoara l'antenne maintenant ouais ben
heureusement qu'il n'est pas venu c'est
à lui avec nous on va te poser une
question méchante tiens ne crois tu pas
que non saab à dessein ah non en
question mais chante aragon était
méchant
donc ça me prendrait quatre noms mais ça
va très bien il savait même pas si mal
tirée que ça il va pouvoir faire grand
roque et ça reste agréable pour les
noirs mais les banques ne sont pas
idiote c'est un objectif très chiante
pour le foot toi moi quand j'étais petit
j'avais regardé une ligne bourges fait
pas c'est toujours d'actualité ces dames
c'est cette rue d'amiens et tu vois
c'est un peu là bas tu te gêne les noirs
à se développer
tu as déjà joué ou pas du coup j ja mais
pas seulement a pas de swat ont
maintenant en fait quand je joue sajou
votre arme ans que je joue souvent des
rousses au lit mot clé c'est trop
troisième elle serait bon comme question
a souhaité ce qui ne tue pas inquiet que
le cycle championne du monde ne puisse
pas continuer ça paraît quand même très
très grave
un fou rire de l'été va-t-elle survivre
ce serait vous en faites moi devant sur
par rapport à sa vente ou l'interview
pas oui enfin je ne comprends pas cette
édition très irresponsable de tapas
c'est l'édition la plus simple qu'il y
avait à prendre d'annuler mais qu'on ne
tue peu le cran de les forcer à jouer
mais c'est beaucoup quoi c'est beau
c'est beau nom qu'avait pris en g2 ils
attaquaient ils attaquent paix cette
note sur pas mal pour les blancs pour
les noirs pardon mais bon les blancs
sidéral un passage ans attaqué sur la
colonne j'ai on verra mais pour
l'instant ils doivent faire face à tours
de 8 communes il l'appareil l'appareil
il s'est déclaré pour des huit jamais
possible annonce quatre figures phares
le type de moteur alors qu'il devra t'on
ces incidents n'existerait pas donc
exempts des noirs sont mieux avec un peu
plus mais bon c'est du blitz et des
blancs voici de s'activer sur le roi
essaie de faire de contrôle jours
gratuits dont tout le monde voire même
deux mois je suis allé chercher ça va je
vois tour je pense pour commence pour
commencer peut-être je me peux te les
menaces possibles et h4 sa rivale bonne
chose parce que ce soit en rendons tous
les pions c'est pour aller aider la
structure adverse et lang quatre heures
à l'avancé patients qu'ils puissent
prendre ce qu'il ya ça s arrête tu vas
faire ton jamais montant junte qu'elle
est bien placé je sais pas mais je vais
quand même pas idiot il faut revenir en
f1 5 du projet s'est pas mal passé le ko
l'issue peut être un peu chez clichés
qui collent mais monte à même de vous
demandent de remettre le lien si tu peux
dans le château dam des trois il protège
tout tir et il prend lâche 4 non pas
autour de 6 je sais pas où tombait 4
août où quelque chose n'est tombé si
c'est pas idiot autre master preuve
insiste que doubler les tours jumelles
du match autant principe pourquoi parce
que la tournée de m
en tout cas ça s'est mieux passé que
comme coup prendre un pion ouais mais
c'est pas si coup en fait banon simple
on obtenait en toile des vies tout je
sais pas mais si jamais un aussi bon
j'ai pas peur mais si je pouvais
économiser vais gérer mon kayak cinq
éléphants d'un g7 j'allais pas peur nous
l'avons fait des coups comme tour des
huit ou quoi et et pas jouer des coudes
défense pour une écoute des enfants adam
4 je pense doit attendre
oui oui oui tu connu le 2 mai mais
lorsqu'il veut les moeurs et ça ça est
sûre ça que je voulais faire à terme 4
et 15 assure france et gorgée d'eau
je suis pas vraiment prendre l'a4 bombay
à tous les coups sont bons mais oui h4
c'est qu'à d'autres lui prends ma douche
comprends pas trop pourquoi laisser en
vie longtemps comment longue temps fait
il peut te faire h5 passent pas très
grave h5 en soi mais géré par l'asse
toujours relou non à la phase 5 par
exemple ces rouleaux il ne fait pas mais
s'il avait fait c'était un peu relou wen
dans la soupe chaude
tu peux ne plus être là il ne serait
plus là bas quelques atrocités relou
alla se joue vite il va des petites
erreurs sur la fin mais la partie était
pas mal joué très bien avec 5 revient
plus mon bts h5 sur le peigné et
regagner la rive en abscisse tu sais pas
et sur un truc qui roule c'est bien mais
si candidate ou day banon lhermitte il
n'y a pas de candidat plus de candidats
parce que puisque report non on va juste
je te je te conseille ce temps vide
qu'on parle de ça d'aller sur la chaîne
youtube de bitstream et battu tout
expliquer on a déjà parlé tout le début
du stream ici ce fait déjà 50 minutes
une heure
et voilà que vers des lève tous les
jours à la fin des combats en fait oui
et aussi beaucoup de stream sur blé
stream qu'on vous dise dijoux abattoirs
facile d'ailleurs il s'en sort pas mal
bizarre car oui mais oui monsieur ya
mieux à faire pour savoir que ça mais
ils ont failli toucher 5 faut aussi
souligner - 2 août cc6 c'est pas mal en
fait ce qu'il a fait avec son cahier b5
du coup nous en sépare de se mêler aux
autres que les n'aura le temps de faire
ses seins il faut quelque chose qui n'a
pu nomansland aval qu'est il réussit à
voir le plan maintenant atteint 23 45
oui non mais là maintenant lequel il pas
si facile de battre un joueur à 1300
quand il a la bonne prépa ben quand il a
besoin facile qu'elle est bonne
référence
et c'est que c'est pas si simple
vraiment du golfe pas de battre un mec
même avec un petit niveau de 13 cents et
s'il guérit connais bien c'est
l'ouverture c'est une position qui sont
pas trop compliqué bah tu vas pas le
scotch et en tout cas je pense qu'il est
déjà mieux enfin il n'y a pas trente
sept ans un sentier à 35,6 bongay
grossistes ou processes de toutefois
faux procès et et reprendre j'ai nommé
ronde un projet qui est bon et même ça
c'est pareil parce qu'au final ils
attaquent cavale est toujours l'équipe
ont cessé ce qui peut broder des trucs
f5 pour tokyo kg qu'elle ne soit plus
protégé toujours un fief c'est un grand
un truc quoi
ok les franges pas trop aimé par contre
trop passifs pain c'est pas il va pas ce
retrait forcément très mal mais il y
avait beaucoup de bien faire tu essaies
fois f5 wacheux 3 pts - porte mais plein
de kookaï processes c'était bien
qu'absente flex ogutu beaucoup d'options
plus sympa que de recul une pièce n'est
ce pas encore perdu nombre de maîtres le
pion des bois paquet propres fonds
propres de ces cinq de nom oui mesdames
ces trois malades ou lot et tu n'es
place d'un programme qui soutient celle
qui est prend des trois hommes
franchissent en fait aimer il défend pas
ma chaise soubise il ya là il fait des
bons coups bas
c'est dommage ça doit le voir
normalement c'est une blague tout ce
qu'il a dit que les signes d'ouverture
mais ce n'est pas la faute de la fille
de robert et c'était vraiment très en
colère ce stream
là bas c'est bien ensuite au ski quoi
est ce par la faute de la fidh s'est pas
fait c'est jamais de sa faute
non mais on va dire que je vais faire
une communication officielle à dire que
de la merde et c'est pas de leur faute
et qu'ils ont tous bien fait donc
c'était près c'était prévisible
ils vont se défendre c'est pas moi qui
suce et pour l'intérêt des échecs
elles font tous tout le temps quel côté
de partout dire qu'il faut juste pas les
écouter en fait on s'en fout dites-vous
de conneries par être seul en retour
entre vous c'est très bien bravo ça n'a
aucun intérêt car ils vont faire ça tout
le temps quoi toute façon c'est
fantastique comme d'hab font la
politique forte de ses chansons le bien
commun c'est triste c'est génial parce
que c'est jamais de la faute de personne
tout fait tout très bien ils sont tous
très bien intentionnés
leur discours tout le temps ils ont tous
retrouvé un argument a posteriori pour
dire que c'était fondé que si que ça
passe au dessus de tout ça vous mentez
voilà c'est tout reagan qui en fait
c'est qu'ensuite c'est que quand suite
office qui a été atteint directement par
la situation qu'il a stoppé le tournoi
en battant bochum ouest
si toi même je voulais rentrer mois vous
pensez qu'il ya des chances d'être viré
non bon peut-être va à peu près moi je
sais pas je sais pas comment il est déjà
là en premier lieu on va jouer à dire
alors ce qu'il a apporté des voix est ce
qu'il ya des soutiens à ce qu'il ya des
pistons après je sais pas et tout un
truc de politique moi j'y connais pas
grand chose mais voilà on parle d'échec
mais même dans la vie réelle tu as des
gens qui s'ils foutent là en fait
bailly connaissent rien dit 10 connerie
sur connerie ils sont toujours là en
fait ça fait 40 ans il est toujours là
donc bon ce qui a fait ce n'est parfois
pas pour autant que ça vient peut-être
des peuples sûrement pas on change le
parti oui madame en moyenne tournoi
invaincu baisse est fantastique
mais mm aimerais tu va énervé comme
bravo reine attend le jardinier à tiens
c'est marrant c'est d'avoir connu sa
terrible et par autres en fait c'est
bien ce qui fait pendant que kg cinq
potes attaqué flotte des cinq blocs
pions prend un visage n'est pas fou par
fodé 5 bien si on prend et dessus
normand que ya cinq ans vous avez même
une deuxième vente pas vexer bessin pour
dégager le flou ça paiera pion qui font
faux bond est simple mais on peut faire
dame prend des cinq ans natale j'ai deux
dans la tête le flou on défend m 7
du coup on préfère tout 17 jeux soit
diagonale faire grand ras quand vous
allez vendre comme ça qui sont
intéressantes mais le grand coup sûr
reprend des 5 c'est juste bon
avant d'enlever le king 6 6 et de faire
cas liés à cette attaque le fou bon on
gère les blancs foulée cinq échecs aussi
partent ailleurs ils perdent des cinq
pour rien voilà on comprend les noirs se
retrouve avec un tour - mais bon dans ce
développement se fout des trois îles
gêne quand même le développement du pion
des du phocéen et compagnie donc les
noirs vont sortir leur toutes les fuites
faire petit rock etc etc etc et g5 c'est
un peu rien donc pour le prix d'un pion
ya pas mal de contre jour
mais en faisant ça bien joué de la part
de blanc qui viennent pourquoi au moins
faire aussi ça va bien se passer
mais ouais bon bah non c'est bien pour
les blancs mais au moins avancés à un
peu jouable
royer fuite rue 8 le poème comme dans la
partie située à la presse vous prend des
cinq pions moité des rockets été
défoncée et voilà du coup d'oeil et
clermont il matto prochain mais on va
super génial vous est parti plus forte
mais assez rare de voir d'anissa les
skis ce que dany est très salam sall et
non mesdames il est très sympa très
ouvert toujours positif et c'est très
américain s'y connaître mais là on peut
pas soutenir ce qu'ils ont fait tu as
beau être le plus positif possible c'est
trop de la merde c'est a mis en danger
beaucoup de gens tu as fait dépenser de
l'argent à pas mal de compagnie les
sponsors là bas les gens qui suivent au
tournoi comme des moyens des trucs pour
rien mais tout ça parce que toi tu
voulais que ça ait lieu et qu'il a fêté
cette petite ronde dans mon coin ouais
c'est non mais fier pour voir dan issa
laye faut vraiment y aller il est jamais
salam sall est normalement salem le mans
battu 1 up vos motos 100 je me retiens
pas que cela en fait on n'est pas sur
giz stream ont peut-être qu'on n'aurait
pas avoir un ton aussi violent je sais
pas ce que tu as comme l'an passé je
vais me faire taper sur les doigts ou
quoi je pense qu'ils veulent ici sont
d'accord en fait ils sont 100 salam sall
est aussi un nom tout monde et salam
sall et non mais c'est pas précipité
être autrement en fait jusqu'au mans
suivre non mais je pense la planète et
est conçu en fait de ce qui s'est passé
est ok mais surtout arrêter trop des
scuds fait amende honorable
oui on s'est trompé c'est de la merde on
a cru que c'était une grippette je sais
pas a dit ce que vous les aimez mais
venez pas nous dire non pas tout bien
fait si sa femme on ça mêmes regrets ils
vont le faire pourtant ça qu'ils vont
proposer un nom mais robert ray ce
revers est ce aussi très énervé a marre
et où les tous les tous les gens entre
guillemets normaux normaux et énervé que
j'essaye dit maintenant tu fais ça c'est
bon bout mais on va tendre à atténuer
l'excès lieux en l'état mais au moins
vous vivez le tournoi bon c'est plus ou
moins n'importe quoi mais au bout de
votre truc et puis bon bah voilà pour
faire ça en plus est travaillée de la
vie contre l'avis de tout le monde pour
pour te rendre à l'évidence à bout d'un
moment c'est pire donc on a une petite
berlinoise ouais et donc certains
cavaliers h4 par des caches cinq tours à
6 comme lucho qui s'est le plus le truc
de alpha 0 kheddache 4 est restée pas
bac ça va du matériel mais super génial
écoute qui se débrouille pas mal qui va
et c'est peut-être de pousser sa petite
majorité de pions et alors on va brûler
il coûtera super génial et par mauvais
super génial et sur les discordes
non mais je me connais je connais pas
mal mais tu connais je sais que c'est il
est super génial comme une tortue
je pensais que c'était un rapport avec
avec les lego un jeu ça va chauffer au
niveau supérieur
les à une chanson de compte c'est super
génial centre est europe déjà plutôt
fait froid je pense même réussite sur ce
que la main et quasiment chauve un raid
après ces deux noms pouvoir bouger le
roi danse leurs petits pions mais je
crois que les noirs ont commencé à
dominer alors tant qu'on faisait froid
c'était solide ce peuple à tanger
internet pour voir si encore dany avec
geof qui j'ai quasiment envie de les
mettre en direct en fait pour écouter je
précise cela peut intéresser les gens à
aimer toi tu pourras pas entendre notre
fils que tu veux quoi quand on quand
j'entends pas non mais attends je vais
juste une seconde juste voir les têtes
je veux voir des têtes aussi l'air
tellement salam sall rsg jamais vu comme
ça quoi mais vraiment repérer si leïla
visage fermé tout a l'impression qu'il
est à dire celle as envoyé lui le vrai
faux l'ambulance de partout quoi vous
aurez désormais laisse caylar sg presse
a eu des crises et live dans le chat
[Rires]
même meilleure alliée dans le château
réveillère est réservée connaissez-vous
quoi faut être coûte chaîne 6 dit non il
est beaucoup moins de chance robert
c'est la nba ça oui il a le visage très
fermé et on verra ce que j'avais vu
comme ça que major un saut qui va le
mans c'est extraordinaire que celle as
non mais des styles aux ils ont raison
de nier tout le monde à la mairie a même
dany danic et 80 ans rue bellegarde gard
regarde sa bouche
rigaud le pot au noir
vas-y je l'écris un jury firent un mail
à junon doit dany augmentation va je
l'écrive augmentation corona issou
augmentation harcourt or corona quoi
mais tu l'as déjà vu comme ça dany
non non mais là il est très fermé savez
vous nous tapez de suivre un talent et
jean le chat s il faut que tu les
interrompre une nouvelle fois mais voir
un match comme super finale mensuelle de
[ __ ] manu chao t-il dit château
présents il a dit merci coca non mais
bon tu peux le taper dessus de son lit
d'un écran ce soir s'annonce difficile
et ils font de médard professionnelle
mais ça a énervé et je peux le
comprendre
robert est d'aller à illies roberge par
exemple plus près ce brevet est lé genre
fils dhani on n'a pas signalé quoi
ailleurs mais vivante saint paul
maintenant il ramait qui fuit dans le
tchat nous avons besoin d'avoir la vie
de robert est là c'est beau la cie pas
content que c'est normal c'est pas mal
la partie c'est un truc où les langues
et une qualité je précise des f-35 d'amd
5 faut défendre avec la dame qui doit
défendre sa duo français 7.8 méthode
quirion pls et du faire plein de thèmes
vous au centre
ces demandes compliqué tu vas enfin ça
fait un peu partie de dix neuvième
siècle intéressante mais c'est beau
bimbo simple j'ai peu à baie saint paul
ne suis pas là depuis imbéciles mais bon
tu veux faire doubler cette année six
donc là là là là il va y avoir un
démontage en règle
fabien grammy qui en fait va passer sur
czech comme du coup pour
donner son avis quoi abattre amis qu'il
est prévu que les billets je commenterai
pas cette mère d'antoine
il ya deux raisons il ya peut-être une
raison pour laquelle il passe sur czech
comme après on me parle et on ne sait
pas où tu as des infos chalon mais oui
oui du coup il va en parler sur check up
donc rami qui va venir et tout ça a
saigné non mais c'est peut-être on doit
passer ce truc là j'en sais rien
j'aimais ce que vous voulez regarder
l'aréna ou du coup vous voulez qu'on
fasse kramnik byron chroniqueurs on peut
le mettre
ouais façon tu peux écouter un portable
et ont fait traduction et où ils veulent
qu rami qui veulent cramique il va être
salam sall et cramique une famille que
je veux dire que c'était irresponsable
machin c'est évident entre arriva les
défenses et non mais il avait prévenu
chronique il a fait une lettre ouverte
il a tout fait on pourra pas lui vers
lui aussi oui tu changes d'avis après
coup non non non non il y a plein qui
vont dire oui j'ai toujours dit et puis
faites vous avez j'aimerais animer la
chronique hui on peut pas dire si il a
fait un communiqué il a refusé de
commenter donc une encre ami qui va leur
mettre très cher dit du kram nick va
leur mère très très cher bah oui disent
que personne qui voit la tête de rennes
chez de presse en temps normal ils sont
très souriants ils sont très heureux
pilotes pendant le live ou alors mais
surtout elle sans s'arrêter impression
que y passerez votre france ait rôle à
fond il faire péter un plomb quoi c'est
la sds part souvent le chat déambulaient
c'est a pu comprendre car l'aï lu sur
twitter domine candidats maintenant
terminé la partie la plus dure
maintenant c'est de rentrer chez moi
come back home jours 12 heures en gros
et exerçant dans un monde que je
reconnaîtrais plus meilleur il en train
de défoncer suite office qui est dit de
toute façon la russie aurait pu à
n'importe quel moment
donner une possibilité d'avoir un double
assure d'arriver brahms erlach
évidemment c'est ce qu'ont à dire il a
raison de dire c'est beau en fait tous
les gestes comme sont très normaux quand
je suis très content babin et ses
compagnies normale avec des gens normaux
en fait ouais non mais il faut pas
attendre et expliqué dans des causes
comme ça tu te rates pour le range sur
des arguments débiles enfin les
meilleurs il te dit de toute façon il ne
pouvait jamais sur qui a les joueurs
pour leur entrée à la chez eux quand ils
ont démarré le tournoi va donc cesser
parce c'est pas ce n'est pas un argument
assez bonnes raisons non mais tu
t'excuses platement toi tu démissionnes
il y va des objectifs est de la merde je
me suis trompé je parle bien d'autres
battues tu dois même pas cherché à
justifier des chocs ou satin est fort
kovic sur le truc pareil si j'essaye de
choper les gars désolé ce qu'ils sont
vraiment venu voir le tournoi mais là et
comme l'arena on comprend que sa mort
est très important mais pas quand même
ça me paraît assez important l'interview
quoi je pense pas la regarder ensemble
nous regardent comme une cause des
joueurs
c'est à la fois revenu tous les sens
[Musique]
sports6 en classe bourgeoise me courir
aucun risque sanitaire
c'était juste spéciale pour les voir
c'est sûr qu'il faut rentrer à la maison
[Musique]
preacher cité des demandes au niveau des
tests pour le chrono courant de
commencer par l'expérience et nous
[Musique]
en accord et création de décision de la
fis d2 quittée pas très expérimenté dans
l'affairé des conseillers de ville ont
approuvé la nouvelle 3 c'est pas sa
décision
nico rosberg est difficile de soi contre
le fait de reporter le temps sont
reportés jeudi au petit matin
[Musique]
si les stations des taux ces flux de
camions de dire que les joueurs devaient
jouer normalement ce qu'ils sont c'est
l'impression que le tir au but
mr est malade sa femme désorientée c'est
tout seul a permis non pas chez toi
dans tous les cas c'est mon précieux
habituel toi tu n'as pas de mental
on va être de retour avec de nouveaux
invités quoi vous êtes très intéressante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très intéressant mais on va rendre
mais quoi on va voir voir le grand
l'aréna qui apprend revient dans 'the
way on est ravis qu on reste sur le coup
quoi l'amérique akrami chanson regard
immédiatement qu'enfin le daniel litres
très pro très bon je garde un oeil
dessus ça parce que ça ça mon avis ça va
reprendre très bientôt la garde d'un
petit son j'entends le piquet de doodle
leur petite musique avec vichy tout ça
allait bien non mais je pense que les
gens c'est ce qu'ils ont ri plus envie
de regarder ça peut te faire alors on
fait la reynard pendant que ça pendant
que ça ça mais la poste une chance c'est
plus intéressant de regarder ça
aujourd'hui quoi oui c'est un peu
l'actualité dernier rien qui lui lancer
des piques dans ces questions n'empêche
ouais il était un peu en mode
provocateur mais qui se passe il a
quitté maintenant mais tout le monde est
dépassé par les croissances
exponentielles
maintenant on a critiqué avant tout
c'est vrai que là l'événement a commencé
assez tard enfin toutes étaient déjà
annulés et public des champions il y
avait plus y'a plus rien en fait déjà et
avait fait un manoir de ton a commencé
le 17 mars dont il ya neuf jours donc
rappelé on m'a dit où dans neuf jours
il ya neuf jours jouda l'italie ça l'est
pas du tout il ya beaucoup de morts
l'espagne avait la vague qui étaient là
la chine se faisait déjà bien deux mois
trois mois que voilà on savait très bien
en france où on était déjà confié oui
bon qu'on fait ce seuil et vers le
nouveau ben c'était déjà ça mais exiger
le ticket com plus trop quelle pourrait
commencer le 3 mars par exemple oui là
tu te dis bon ça va
bon ok y'a le corona où ça s'est fait
oui mais si là le truc c'est que on
avait tout le problème
faut-il y aller s'ils avaient déjà en
russie ça et puis de toute façon les
joueurs devaient se déplacer d'autres
pays donc ils sont reportés à caen à ça
on sait pas en commençant le 3 mars il
finissait il aurait pu à minima reporté
d'une semaine ou deux voir comment ça
évolue aussi de base tous les jours
emmanuel 13 aurait plus de 2 le design
très clairement on attend le 22 23 à
voir l'évolution et voir si on commence
ou pas il n'aurait pas annulé les avions
ça continuera oui mais ça change de 10
ans mais bon les avions du ce là déjà
apparemment ils rentrent avec un vol
privé
il aurait pu le faire voler le vol dans
15 jours je pense c'était possible aussi
où il aurait pu trouver une solution si
vous voulez vraiment c'est même pas seul
problème c'est que son ingestion été
calamiteuse
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer et
aiderait ils ont regardé la vidéo de m
yoyo ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se
passer bien se passer
inquiète pas c'est pas possible c'est
juste tournoi pour pas mal
crowley ouais non mais moi je suis
quasiment sûr que ce truc là c'est une
fausse excuse aux siens je pense qu'il
ya autre chose qu'on sait pas en fait il
qu'ils ont pris le premier truc venu
pour les jours à venir regarder on peut
pas on est très responsables on pense
aux joueurs pour qu'ils rentrent chez
eux mais à mon avis à quelque chose
d'autre
c'est allé très bizarre leur
communication je trouve c'est bizarre
d'être emmené eu beaucoup de joueurs
connus de son box est un pro du truc ne
se donne pas il parle bien il ne tremble
pas quoi bah c'est son métier un buisson
rouge bien meilleur que surtout ils sont
passés ici mal du mal si l'on ignorait
c'est pas pareil nikita et gorod ouais
ouais je sais pas ou alors ils sont où
c'est possible
mais c'est vrai que les avis enfin les a
vus en fait c'est l'excusé la plus bidon
puisque de toute façon ils prennent un
avion privé c'est un non sens politique
oui ça a annoncé un politicien de la
vraie politique de voir kobe tu attends
il ya un an et kathryn bigelow
il propose a dit que pour ça commence
quand c'est difficile
arrivé dans l'histoire mais pour cela on
trop de temps à réfléchir de la première
place la pression là rendez vous plus à
[Musique]
700 social c'est arrivé pendant le
tournoi
genre made in a way points
seule équipe du crlc plus possible mais
qu'en est il avec fierté
le résumé que mon bac façon vu comment
la gauche et dignitaires batterie ça
bastonne de koné sexton est donc l'un
[Musique]
des seigneurs de l'avant le début des
candidats majeurs les confettis billets
qui tombe
[Musique]
si tu as est uni que jamais arrivé avant
le sursaut a links with événements qui
se sont passés la chine xi a confié
d'aignan et pratiquement de toutes
façons moment l'équation
j'avais des joueurs de rigoler que vous
avez fait pour le grenadien toujours
directement et j'ai pas vu que moteur du
jeu c'est l'une des crises et que radio
foot et plus si tu regarde toutes les
vidéos qu'on a fait on on rigole à dire
le montage que tu veux faire dire aux
gens ce que tu veux
houston safe et qu'on caresse hilal
coronas pas possible pics hockey
prochain c'est cramique olap à 13 ans
une blague et robert verdier hyper
énervé il est hyper énervé prochain
kramnik mécanique ça est intéressant je
pense mais moi je pense qu'il peut avoir
ya peut-être un quart parce que attend
qu'ils vont ceux d'annie seul on va
laisser n'y a peut-être fait un cap
c'est quand même le cas d'antoura
déchets qu'ils ont fait un gros match là
il ya deux semaines en fait ce que
disait vanina sur son facebook avec une
en russe et que jamais personne il a
répondu c'est 1,4 corolla ils ont été
dégagés mis en quarantaine
c'est pas c'est le corona une pneumonie
en fait ils ont découvert juste une
semaine ou dix jours après qu'il ya
vingt quatre corona juste à peut-être
quelqu'un dans l'hôtel où quelque part
qu'il a eue quoi et ils veulent pas dire
c'est aussi très possible les russies
communique un minimum là dessus donc ce
que la vraie raison ce soit ça ça qui
cache les chiffres en disant qu'il ya
pas de cours demain mais il ya des
pneumopathies pour beaucoup une aumône
il a donc à avoir on va voir donc ouais
en fait serrer un cas toute façon je ne
dirais pas maintenant il vient et que
dans une semaine deux semaines ou jamais
ils veulent peut-être se blinder
derrière pas dire en plus a mis en
danger les gens que c'est un employé
d'hôtel quelqu'un et c'est aussi
possible
moi je trouve que le l'argument de dire
ils peuvent pas rentrer chez eux parce
qu'il ya plus de voix qui sortent de
russie quand tu peux a affrété des jets
privés s'il ya un problème pour moi il
ya quelque chose il ya quelqu'un dans la
paire vision un peu tu peux sortir de
russie
oui sans avion et puis tu fais un avion
après ailleurs après de sibérie ce peu
tendu quand même c'est le transsibérien
basse et longwy tu passes par moscou
suite eu ben arfa tu mets trois jours
peut-être 28e y avait quoi mais bon de
toute façon c'est que les vols réguliers
qui sera renouvelée c'est pas les voilà
privé donc le jet privé marche mais oui
non pour l'histoire de radjabov pour
revenir juste et plus qui racontait quoi
je paye son commentaire non cette vidéo
était content quand maxime etc
toujours est il avant que le tournoi a
commencé quand un mec qui aime bien dit
et voilà après radjabov sac et une
communication étonnante tout au long de
depuis six mois en disant de base oui je
sais pas si j'ai joué je suis pas motivé
et patati patata
pourrait sembler être un prétexte ou
quoi en tout cas depuis on a appris que
c'était préparé à fond avec car yakine
donc il va pas bluffé il est passé du
temps à s'entraîner à fond et tout cas
la raison qu'il a donnée semble très
valide donc c'était pas de la pleutrerie
pour le cool ouais on va voir un du
tournoi side dans les règles a abrité du
tournoi dans les tous les trafics des
résultats reste vrai nom mais bon pour
pour moi est quelque chose de il ya
quelque chose qui colle pas il ya
quelque chose qui colle pas ouais non
non il ya quelque chose qui colle pas
fable wicked les piles paul à la moitié
pour valider les résultats
thierry marx le hasard ça non mais ya ça
il ya le fait que les vols soient
arrêtés mais qu'en fait toute façon ils
prennent des prenne un avion
on sent la caméra tué l'info mais c'est
beau ce qu'on nous a dit et si ils
prennent tous le même jusqu'à maintenant
mais ça s'en va le priver ses 50 cas où
60 cas vous sans caméra par là que c'est
moins cher que de reporter de toutes
façons de faire prendre à valprivas tout
le monde jusqu'à amsterdam ou paris où
ils veulent
ce sera toujours moins cher que de faire
repartir tout le monde puis revenir puis
trouver des dates quelque chose qui pour
moi qui collent pas à tirer son nom d'un
candidat
mais voilà ces chroniques qui qui qui
refusait de se fonder sur place 24 ski
trouvé que ce n'était pas normal de
faire le tournoi
c'est sûr que là philippe rey hyper de
plus que qu'un vol ekatérinbourg
amsterdam en avion mais c'est évident en
terme d'image aussi ça va ça va être
quelque chose un petit peu quelque chose
alors attends chronique bonjour non plus
comme tout
[Musique]
deux motos sport du week end au finish à
faire en deux jours avant il a dit que
cette tenue est donc ce dans tous les
cas un enfant est allé au cours du
premier vingt
[Musique]
sans provision
dorothy stick to reach russia and which
is simply mais les motos de type
existent ou non ils s'attaquent
maintenant est ce exact
[Musique]
avec deux montées dont le tournoi tous
les experts internationaux et les
élections en russie soit né sur le
territoire
c'était faux
deuxième le dépenser en plus grave que
prévu white ou bien encore infosport
récupération wayne général il faut
suivre les règles de tri des sachets sur
le reste du monde comme 30 août 2010
[Musique]
à ces idées vous savez tout le truc pour
die et les prochains jours n'est pas
pour sauver la situation km et b mais
non c'est un peu bizarre non le récit
par on est un peu les angles mais
[Musique]
ça vient tout seul en assistant aux
tournois de haut niveau grimm topic
seulement maintenant d hadopi pour vous
divertir cet opéra losc ou récemment
c'est chabal on ne laisse pas son nom
enfin je suis en tout cas bravo tu n'es
jamais rien vu de loin on dirait travers
la situation voilà mon pied des marinas
c'est bon ça c'était quand même
intéressant mais bon pas tant que ça
quand j'ai une ouïe qui a gagné devant
aarau oliver 13 victoires 0 défaite 1 0
du bolivar les shows et paquito finaux
qui a fini 3e mais non mais c'est
intéressant en groupe et c'est vrai
qu'il parle un peu de la même manière
que nous quoi par rapport à cette
situation va bien il a un peu les mêmes
armes mais il donne une solution bon moi
qui ai intermédiaire enfin que ce
qu'elle vaut mais bon des faillites a
souhaité jeudi que oui il n'y a pas
d'autre solution qu'il en soit ça c'est
clair a annoncé radio par an suivant
voilà on va voir a dit ruff la fantasy
quoi ça enchaîne comme un fou bon bah
regarder quoi mais ils sont chauds de
chasse car en fait il invite tout le
monde à déjà 9
[Musique]
serait hyper et super six mois je serai
très générale et en direct déjà que moi
je suis énervé mois mais voilà je
défonce savez quoi
on m'a dit hakim ait dit ça cramique
normes et vont jusqu'à solution pour
votre carte 2022 ça résoudrait non tu ça
résout pas le problème de ce candidat là
qui gâchent les tirs étaient donc tu
fais un truc pour le futur pour calmer
le mec mais peut-être faire bon ok c'est
mieux que rien mais je dois faire c'est
en planche
tu as vraiment père saison blanche puis
avant que n'y a pas de solution la
meilleure solution c'est peut-être ne
pas en prendre
non mais tu fais comment d'autres non
mais je sais pas il ya pas de mai - tu
maintiens le match en décembre saison
blanche et tu fais le match-clé caruana
karl scène n'a pas le choix
pas de match enfin on verra en juin mais
pas de quoi tant pis ou tu recommandes
ce cycle de qualification 2021 et tu
vois et tu joues en 2022 ou du fait un
double truc tu refais des qualifiés puis
sera un candidat
quatorze joueurs bassi saison blanche la
juke aouana légitime
il a gagné des candidats donc ses
saisons blanches c'est comme dans tout
les trucs mais c'est comme la solution
de la so foot qui dit bon cette année
auront pas le classement prend le
classement de l'année dernière bat
dernière fois c'était lui et ça que
c'est une option si on y pense pour le
foot pour qu on n en serait pas là
mais même au tennis ils font ça j'avais
quand même les classements tu continues
à donner les points atp
de monte carlo enfin pierre flynn il
aurait peut-être gagné monte-carlo et
40ème ses livres pour l'atp mais un nom
mais peut-être le sens que juste pas de
match 2020 tu refais un sigle ce titre
ils sont tous bien foutu dans la merde
en fait en ayant imposé que ces
candidats aient lieu et alors qui est
très peu de chances que ça puisse se
finir quel maintenant fatah sont
situation quoi que tu fasses c'est
pourri donc tu as utilisé quand ils
surmonter cette année au foot saison
blanche en fait c'est pas du tout en
fait hein c'est non mais en italie 10 ha
et je pense ce pas combattu vingt jeunes
à 22 l'an prochain les deux premiers
montent voilà tu as fait ton calendrier
bombail sauf qu'en france - un bloc de l
est du coup ça te faire votre place dans
le calendrier puis c'est comme ça mais
oui bah j'ai relâché même celui que tu
as tu la joues pas enfin je sais pas
c'est très compliqué de sang tous les
sports c'est très bizarre
hélas pour les échecs il aurait pu faire
un truc simple c'était de ne pas jouer
ce tournoi et de jeu et quand ça ira
mieux et du coup tout allait bien at il
sauvé leur truc il avait rien à dire là
maintenant qu'ils ont fait ça ça devient
très compliqué même si les gens me
disent tu reprends quoi mais du coup
quelle est l'équité pour dingli rennes
d'avoir gelé cette première ronde de ce
tournoi
ben y'a pas n'ya pas d'équité de rien en
fait donc ses il n'y a pas de bonne
solution
cc c'est horrible en fait non et que tu
gardes le classement actuel
donc là et tu reprennes à 0 tu tu
laisses pas des mêmes personnes mais tu
laisse forcément des gens donc future
prend 0 tu l'aise
mv les dépôts principalement si situe à
prague le classement actuel bas par mme
dingli jan
je sais pas pourquoi on viendrait jouer
que ces deux points et demi là alors
qu'elle vient de taper deux mois de
confinement qui est passé par moscou que
tu vas force est restée 14 jours c'est
le seul qui va sur ça et on voit qu'il
n'est pas toute sa tête pour jouer que
ça l'est pas caruana qui a pris 50 vols
pour venir qui est en retard c'est pas
comment il allait rentrer chez lui
en fait tous ces gens là si tu les
refait jouer en mettant de fait sans qu
il n a pas pu défendre leurs chances à
100%
quoi que tu fasses tu laisses quelqu'un
sera pas même personne et quoi qu'ils
fassent tu as du goût c'est tout donc il
ya forcément de concert
[Musique]
je ne suis pas être rythmée au son
ce froid et des chutes à ok
de retour de mission légale qui sont
fort bien
evènement le timeline
un des fidèles de match en fin de match
[Musique]
m
et à des hausses de 9 à 10 h les french
or nothing staff avec nos familles et
nos amis
j'avais ou quoi mais qui suffit de
regarder les gens en général et complet
l'internement soit 10 de taux
[Musique]
molina doivent être très longtemps qu il
aussi
[Musique]
le groupe pour faire un petit résumé
fava ait dit que il a eu des
informations en gros et c'est un peu ce
qu'on a pensé ce qu'on a
c'était parce qu'on a pensé on a pensé
que c'était possible et d information vu
que il a quand même s'est il a ses hauts
placés quoi ça bien établie il est très
très rare italie on rappelle sa femme et
richissime et qu'il avait des
informations de gens qui voulaient pas
citer pour pas les mettre dans
l'embarras mais tu disais que ça allait
très grave
le l'épidémie et que du coup il a
contacté la fidh et avec ces
informations et à dieu qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire quelque chose il faut prévoir
quelque chose en cas d'épidémie mondiale
et fort kovic madiba nom c'était une
grippette quoi en gros je caricature
mango qu'il n'y avait rien de grave et
tout bon bah du coup ils ont fait un
ultimatum pour savoir s'ils devaient
jouer ou pas fan lui dit que c'est eux
qui ont fait du petit matin plutôt que
l' inverse
on va dire qu'il a pas répondu mais que
comme il aura et gré écrit le 15 mois
quand
ministère des sports a dit que c'était
interdit de deux de jouer des
compétitions sportives internationales
en russie et on répète les échecs sont
un sport en russie aujourd'hui oui mais
le toit et commence a déjà commencé et
commence avec la cérémonie d'ouverture
du genre étaient arrivées des joueurs
mais pas la cérémonie avec l'arrivée des
joueurs de tournois dont ils ont quand
même joué et bien voilà pas fort en gros
est dit que lui veut être réintégrés au
tournoi et qu'il fasse un trou avec neuf
joueurs quoi mais je pense que vu son
mindset et vu l'interview c'est parti
pour des juridique toussaint bataille
juridique tout ça est à mon avis sont
pas très bien parti parce que il est
très bien établie et je pense qu'il peut
aller faire super fier bah écoute s'il a
des lettres des preuves de ce qu'il
avance est sûrement qu'il les a des
emails des trucs et il va tout ressortir
et puis la crise avec un bond à sa place
je lâcherai rien tout cas ça va finir au
tribunal et en plus il a les moyens mais
bon c'est g kg les copies pas l'écran et
son chéri mon avocat et mon avis c'est
sa femme c'est la feets au quartier un
truc enormissime passe comme si tu as 10
milliards d'euros quoi mais ouais mais
quand on rate jamais un truc comme ça
bah écoute voilà je sais pas trop encore
ajouté ils ont tous bien par des noms
mais je pense que ça peut servir pour
mettre quelque part cette histoire est
crade la bastille va loin ça peut servir
pour mettre un grand coup de pied dans
la fourmilière et peut-être enfin faire
avancer les choses quoi ouais bah
ferrera ce sera lent ça prendra des mois
et toute façon maintenant je peux quoi
dire d'autre votre ça va être longue
on attend le no fake bien évidemment on
l'attend l'épreuve du no fake mais a de
toute façon c'est vrai que le truc du
ministère des sports qui fasse est
possible que le droit était juste
illégal ouais bon après on trouve un
arrangement pour port mais oui non mais
peut-être que vous êtes obligé de faire
un arrangement à l'amiable 10 rebonds
qui est honteux réintègre je sais pas
mais
[Musique]
très compliqué très compliqué et à sang
comme on l'a dit c'est ça tu vas pas il
n'ya pas de bonne solution maintenant
quoi que tu fasses tu les auras du monde
c'est à billy tournoi 9 bah oui enfin
pourquoi pas mais du coup bas vise à
vacciner peau après max il pourra
toujours se dire bon ça et que c'est
chiant mais au cas où je devais pas de
qualifiés dont on sent moins seul
les disques ssd innover par l'express
un leader fort de chemnitz until it can
be done so calais amènent des
circonstances
everything is everything
la faute au saut du lit
[Musique]
en clair comme 56 with à l'économie
en entendant le trucage et pas les
images mais ouais en gros noms ça a fait
tilt truc de carlson et du coup je
trouve qu'il s'est un peu perdu dans
n'importe quoi après dans le fond il a
raison pour moi de lire sur wii dont we
do not in my express mini à cinq des six
touristes intrigués par 2k sports a
forcément intéressant mais du khan
d'ethnie qui dit que comme il a dit
après les candidats et après la coupe du
monde qu'il était pas sûr de jouer à il
n'a plus aucune crédibilité mais ça
c'est un procès d'intention lui dit
qu'il faisait du second degré et qu'il
voulait jouer et en fait s'il est
qualifié c'est un procès d'intention que
dire de toute façon il voulait pas y
aller il avait le droit d'y aller il
était qualifié et tu peux dire ce que tu
veux dans une interview c'est c'est par
batterie légal non sinon déclare quelque
chose à j'avais dit ça et il ya six mois
s'est il a le droit d'y aller l'a jamais
dit qu'il voulait pas y aller c'est
préparer il a pris chercher love
dominguez car yakine fallu à payer juste
des gens comme ça pour faire ce qu'il
veut y aller annuler à la dernière
seconde
c'est l'effet qu'ils sont importants
apparemment il dit que c'est pas en
azerbaïdjan je me porte chance de
2faire l'air de rien et dit croire en
secret ouais mais le truc c'est que il
n'est pas crédible une seconde bac coûte
nuit ce qui te dit c'est qu'il se trouve
que le truc de qourna c'était très grave
c'est que il avait raison c'est quand
même assez crédible pas on va lui
enlever après qu'il eut envie pas envie
de jouer que si que sa façon de tort à
notre avis mais quoi qu'il en soit hélas
il envoyer ces lettres à d'hafid il a
reçu sa réponse et qui vas y prends ma
démarche si vous voulez prendre
max 14,210 ticket il a tous le fric qui
veut oui mais c'est pas parce que tu es
riche que t'as pas le droit de
participer aux candidats qu'enfin les
genres c'est un jugement de valeur s'il
veut si les riches tant mieux pour lui
c'est bien qu'enfin on est heureux pour
lui et c'est sur l'échiquier ça change
rien non mais je crois qu'il me dire sur
le feu d'or d'affilée contre des seconds
rôles ce qui veut dire c'est que il
s'est fait un alibi d'un complot mondial
en fait leur job pour moi en tout cas
non mais là bas russie qui montre là il
a l'air d'être mécontents la situation
et d'avoir envie de défendre ses chances
et voilà
[Musique]
ouais non je peux enfin bon moi je suis
con 10 de mieux
or comment la situation ce parce
qu'enfin ça va ça prendra du temps toute
façon ça va être le principal problème
pour l'instant mac à une crise sanitaire
à gérer
n'oublions pas que la situation n'était
pas comme ça quand il a quitté mais si
tu lis les rapports de loin mais s'il se
trouve que si en fait parce que fin
février les rapports de m s était dans
le même nom mais en fait tu fais les
calcules tu savais que ça allait se
passer
juste de le vivre de voir les mardis
reportage télé ou quoi ça te fait un
autre senti que juste de faire des
petits calculs sadaka violent du rawyl
bon il y aura des amis noirs et il va
donc c'est ça qui a changé peut-être
mais en fait c'était prévisible et plein
d sion qui a été prise hier si la ligue
1 ne se joue plus il rugby se joue plus
si les yeux sont reportées si fins il ya
tout ça c'est pas juste un certain
caractère acquis et les pharmaciens
disent ici ça fait des semaines qu'il ya
des conférences des rapports de partout
sur l'arrivée d'une pandémie mais ok
après ils ont pas communiqué au grand
public parce que pour pâques et de
panique ou je ne sais quoi enfin ça peu
importe leurs raisons je suis pas leur
place je sais pas comment je réagirais
si toujours est il que ça pouvait savoir
et juste pour dire il en veut pas du
tout aux autres joueurs où elles veulent
quoi
enfin ce n'est pas la nouvelle façon
lily baradei joue pas est ce que toi tu
veux jouer il va dire oui il paraît
capable en vouloir du coup il a le
simple contre la fidl mais du coup ouais
mais bon juste enfin je ne faut pas
faire de procès d'intention gala on ne
sait pas mais en tout cas ses arguments
y tienne il a assez bien parlé sur ce
qu'on a vu et je pense que oui carlson
qui vient dire oui la peur ma chance un
peu c'est très très moche hein mais je
crois que j'ai lus tard je sais pas si
c'est vrai à voir et vérifier mais qui
le trolley dans le live de faim si le
chambre juste saveur
ouais c'est juste chambre et c'est pas
grave non mais ouais il coûte
non mais radjabov boycott je sais pas
battu vokoun nous passons c'est bizarre
je suis candidat je sais pas pour quelle
raison ils ont tenu à le faire en tout
cas ça n'a pas marché
ils sont mis dans la merde et puis l'on
verra qu'on s'est voulu accepter qu'on
dise de plus calmes et qui sait pas
juste pour lui c'est clair mais d'un
point de vue légal ce sera pas un
argument basse si réussie a approuvé que
le truc le 16 le gouvernement a dit pas
faire le tournoi qu'il a commencé le 17
si réussi à prouver ça et que les
candidats n'étaient pas légaux bâle
également il va avoir raison puisqu'elle
était le contenu de leur courrier tout
ça ça ou sur les lesage
je veux dire nous on n'a pas vu la
lettre on sait pas donc on verra
puis tout a souffert barda on peut avoir
un gars plus long à palier on atteint
les 9 avec malgré ce qui est bien un
truc pas mal et finalement c'est un
genre de lanceur d'alerté ça alors
lanceurs d'alertés sur leur lancée en
alerte il s'en prend plein la gueule au
final crisis n'était pas légale de
lancer la verte
tu a dévoilé un scandale mondial mais tu
sais te retrouve tout de sio finale quoi
donc oui et non c'est vraiment difficile
comme situation honnêtement il faudrait
voir le contenu des lettres et tout ça
on peut pas on peut pas à juger et ils
manquent
il manque de contenu manque de matériel
on n'a pas les preuves des no fake rien
mais je trouve que c'était intéressant
d'avoir d'avoir son opinion et voilà je
pense qu'avant de pouvoir juger de quoi
que ce soit il faut il faut en savoir
plus pour le moment on n'en sait pas
assez raison garder il faudra voir les
développements quoi il autant c'est ça
mais ça sera long voilà on va par une
réponse tout de suite tout de suite dans
tous les cas la fidh a très mal géré
trucks sas et ça c'est une certitude
oui je parle pas de radio pas faim je
pense de l'événement en général ça c'est
une certitude après dans l'espoir
radjabov il faudrait avoir plus de plus
de matériels plus de nos fake
d'après la fidh
non mais je pense que ils ont essayé de
sauver l'intérêt financier en pensant
qu'ils arriveraient à des auteurs maison
pas pris la dimension du sérieux
l'épidémie et ça voilà c'était pas
forcément fait avec des intentions
machiavéliques ou je sais pas quoi mais
tout cas ils ont mal fait la fille née
sous l'autorité du ministère des sports
en russie non mais les six mines ça
respire en russie demande d'annuler
toutes les compétitions sportives
internationales sur son territoire c'est
quand même elle qui tendent à nous qui a
le dernier mot c'est comme en france
c'est pas la fifa qui a le dernier mot
sur les matchs de foot c'est le
gouvernement français ou le préfet
plutôt en france sur non je pense avec
le préfet d'un lézard et tj pas
exactement mais en tout cas c'est pas
les fédérations internationales qui ont
le dessus sur les gouvernements
nationaux pour à l'organisation des
événements
donc là bon sa femme de le faire confie
guy fille d'egate un truc
ouais non mais ça fait c'est l'histoire
il peut aller très très loin en fait il
peut faire un procès aux tasses je sais
pas où enfin à l'eau
voix venant tous les procès sont une
fois un swell son père d'anne aussi donc
et on sait toujours pas vraiment
pourquoi ils ont arrêté plus aujourd'hui
que avant puisque comme on veut et pour
le moment les la vraie raison elle est
quand même très bizarre vu qu'ils ont
arrêtés parce que soi disant ils aient
plus de vols mais ils font quand il ya
calmes et les charters qui peuvent voler
les vols privés donc c'est une excuse un
petit peu étrange aussi pour arrêter par
ya beaucoup de valloire s'il ya plus
personne du contrôle le trafic aérien ou
quoi qui bossent et tu peux vraiment
plus à me faire voler du tout aussi je
sais marc ameil la foulée à faire voler
des trucs en gros il ya c'est moi je
trouve que c'est très opaque là tous car
c'est vraiment très opaque c'est
vraiment difficile de se faire de
comprendre qui dit vrai qui dit faux nom
mais comme diplômés tête ils ont paniqué
avant que les vents ont des malades ou
quoi je sais pas mais après on peut
interpréter comme on veut on n'en sait
pas beaucoup plus que la veille juste
une dernière petite info pour pour
conclure ce live du coup on ne sait pas
mais c'est une info du moscow times
donc c'est quand même je peux je vais
pas le mettre à l'écran là parce que
c'est pas vide screen la chaîne ne fait
pas le faire mais un citoyen irlandais
est hospitalisé en russie unie est
suspecté de coronavirus donc ça a été
c'était le 16 mars
vous allez la veille du développement et
de la première ont donc c'est là qu'ils
ont décidé de tout arrêter sur les
choses sportive et il se trouve que
c'était déjà un tour à des chats qui la
chance tu vois les coïncidences sont un
petit peu un petit peu bizarre là
évidemment voilà les taxes soient
arrêtés donc non mais juste sur c'est
une sorte de petit inconscience ils sont
inquiets des risques qu'ils ont espéré
tout leur coeur ça passerait et donc non
c'est pas une théorie du complot et you
know c'est juste pour dire que ça tombe
ça tombe lesage deux jours ils disent ne
plus vouloir avoir de deux compétitions
sportives internationales sorti ce jour
là dans la presse et il se trouve
c'était aussi un tournoi d'échecs donc
il y avait quand même un bien fondé du
fait de tout arrêter quoi on verra
en tout cas l'histoire va ça va se
développer fab pour le moment mme banon
ne sera rien on sera des spectateurs
attentifs et c'était 1 du coup qu'est ce
que je voulais dire on continue un peu
pendant les rondes à faire des life
choses comme des arénas warfare 2 ans et
puis on décidera après demain comme
s'arrêter jours de repos après on refera
une arena demain midi donc rendez vous
demain peut-être faire de la pédagogie
un petit truc on a hâte rade juste
discuté aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
lymphome natation après cette édition on
doit justement c'est pas plus lourd
c'est même mieux c'est difficile de se
faire donc entendu des gens parler on
n'a pas de fin on a pas de faits et
allait que des hommes qui n'y ont donc
c'est un peu chiant ça enrichit en
discuter sur des opinions bonbons à la
nôtre qu'il faut pas plus mal mais que
ça vu ce qu'on a pas les mêmes quand est
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire rejouer
macha ça hyper dur l'ip est un devoir
interview mvl après une interview de la
nouvelle il pas dans l'avion c'est
encore raté à bord je pense qu'apple va
être dur de le contacter pendant un jour
ou deux bailly doit vite essayer de
rentrer chez lui ok après l'interview
plein de trucs mais l'a déjà laissé le
prendre l'avion que c'est génial
créateur en fait il est venu parler
civile de nouveau en train de faire ses
banques claude à la convention son
stream et la vie de là ça pourrait être
intéressant d'ailleurs
ouais on pourra le demander pour mixed
reebok
du coup le dagens d'accrocher un stream
c'est demain midi et puis tu sais pas
mais à moi ce que j'avais très envie de
faire surtout d'autres joueurs là je
suis peut-être des petites ce soir j'en
sais rien encore mai
mais comme utiliser des football manager
des tft d'autres trucs je sais pas il ya
plus à tête aux échecs la structure je
crois que ça va un peu d'écouté des
échecs pour pour un moment quoi passe la
main sur la tête ces deux c'est
dégueulasse en fait franchement la
situation je sais pas comme je disais je
sais pas qui a raison qui a tort du truc
du machin mais il se trouve que la
situation en général je vais à trouve
détestable en fait oui puisque
maintenant toute façon comme on disait
ils sont une situation insoluble
tu as plus de bonnes solutions rappelons
que vous l'aviez nuit toute façon tous
ces cours ne savent pas jouer à quoi ça
servait ce tournoi vous mettez moi en
face de carousel quest challengeur
est-ce que ça vraiment un intérêt
sportif as j'en doute mais et comment
disait sosei des deux shows d'autres qui
peut vous intéresser si t'es pas écrire
qu'on fasse des choses pendant tout le
confinant ça veut dire un petit moment
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que je hais ce que
enfin de stream là j'en reparle ce soir
je lâche les premières infos sur la
bitstream cap fabre qui reste encore
cinq minutes je monte le client je reste
je sais pas je suis pas chaud car que
c'est de partir mais c'est juste en fait
juste parler de ce truc on n'a pas plus
d'infos et je suis défoncé les uns à
défoncer les autres mais font certains
voient là non mais moi j'avais mon avis
ou où je te dis je tente ici tox qui
tout ça c'est mon avis perso après
peut-être que j'ai le droit de me
tromper que vous êtes très bonnes
raisons
je veux montrer à ces sites vitrines cas
pour en discuter vite fait avec les gens
de théâtre
ouais ça peut être intéressant la vie
d'albert intéressant oui bien sûr moi
j'aime bien très envie d'inviter maxime
sur la chaîne pour n'en fait pas
forcément pour discuter sa part des
partis pédagogique à faire de la
pédagogie de partout attend non mais je
vais la trouver comment en fait je
trouvais comme ça
je vais trouver mon femmes dont un fable
libye tu es bien donc je peux vous
montrer je vous mets lien je vous montre
à l'écran partie pédagogique avec mpl
répartiraient et éternelle non mais
j'espère qu'on verra un peu maxime sur
la chaîne devrait faire chier max irons
voir le récupérer un maximum
non mais il ya mieux en tout ce sont les
regarde il est peut-être mais entre
arafat et qui regarde mais mon beau
diffusion la semaine en train de dire
attendez oui ça aurait très très con
maxime était assez conscients de la
situation quand on l'a vu à maxima il
était il était génial mais au lycée
bravo mais il faut arriver à jouer à
faire abstraction c'était un champion et
moi je fais bravo à ce qu'il a fait en
tout cas et non mais ce que j'aime pas
trop dans le chatt parfois alors je sais
que c'est une minorité mais quand même
je tiens à le dire il ya des gens qui
pensent que quand on dit que radjabov
doit être repris que c'est dégueulasse
radjabov c'est écrit là y en a même un
qui est encore excellent commentaire oui
tu dis ça parce que tu veux pas que
maxime joue mais ça aucun rapport en
fait assez c'est pas bête en est a le
droit d'être objectif
enfin c'est pas parce que on a un copain
qui jouait machin ce serait la même
chose c'était great food avec qui je
suis pote ou là de quoi c'est juste que
tu peux regarder une situation sans
penser au côté personnel oui non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que je sais pas
c'est vrai un match de foot que votre
équipe
il serait dominé tout le match ils eu
six poteaux en face puis vous marquez
sur un but de la main à la fin a le
droit de dire où sont nées de la chance
de gagner était quand même très content
a regagné mais web on méritait pas trop
beau mais bon ça va s'est bien goupillé
est ce que ça veut dire que c'était
contre votre homme étudiant tu parle de
lui en irlande
non mais par exemple tu vois je disais
juste un mot hasard ou georges je suis
un derby
sainté a gagné à lyon s'est fait
défoncer tout le match on a veillé sur
un vrai but un coup franc de payet c'est
joli mais on s'informe la défense et les
sauvetages sur la ligne est plutôt
d'être à c'était un vol en fait bon
j'étais très heureux de gagner le match
mais après tu peux aussi analyser
objectivement à dire oui ou non nous on
était plus forts mais la chance ça veut
pas dire que t'es pas content ça des
fois tu vas être objectif quoi alors
attends j'ai mis les infos sur l'écran
allez quelques infos que j'ai écrit bon
ça c'est un projet qui en courant les
mecs donc on en forme projet il n'y a
rien d'officiel mais j'ai commencéà j'ai
commencé à écrire
en gros l'idée je sais pas si vous voyez
bien l'écran si jamais être plus grand
ça va bien ou pas honneur ben justement
ado bédié aux hongrois de mauvaise foi
dire qu'on n'est plus autres se mêlent
bon le dit des fois en fait des fonds
samuel iphone soit dépendant le truc est
encore un mec qui a écrit en commentaire
que en fait non on n'avait jamais dit
que fait pas jouer les candidats qu'on
s'est fait emmener content pour maxime
qui peuvent jouer la mère baissé de
moitié depuis que feutrée tout ça j'ai
l'impression que il ya des gens dans mes
voix mais en fait bon signe noté je
pense que les gens aiment bien les
délires en général j'aime bien de bonne
humeur et bas ce qui me plaisait pas à
les voir hier en fait c'est tout ce que
je sais qui suis-je dit qu aux dix
autres
vous pensez qu'on est mal intentionnés
mais passez votre chemin
écoutez vous oblige pas à regarder
faites vos devis incroyable je pense que
je suis plus fort que les grands maîtres
machin sinon je me dit non mais c'est
pas le type mais en fait tu vois un truc
que je déteste c'est quand déjà envie de
se prendre à s'en prendre à toi alors
toi tu es là tu es sympa priorité la
visage découvert que c'est un pseudo et
ils viennent te cracher dessus
mais j'aime pas ça bondues vous allez
enfin peut-être que c'est très bien de
se faire chier tu es en général mais moi
j'aime pas en fait c'est bon je me
remets donc ces gens là bas fait votre
vie mais chez va juste passer votre
chemin
d'autres choses obligés de venir vous
n'aimez pas vous aimez pas fait autre
chose je dis donc faire parlons peu
parlons bien oui parlons au bonheur
parlons heureux parle on parle on est
heureux donc l'idée de la visserie cup
pas officiel encore mais c'était de
réunir en gros déjà pour les prix en ce
qui concerne les prêts à le prize pool
le prize pool sera financée par l'argent
des abonnés des sables bitstream comme
ça c'est dit au moins on sait d'où vient
l'argent c'est l'argent des salles non
mais les seules ressources à ce qu'on
fait de l'argent c'est l'argent des
scènes donc les seuls seront là pour
payer alors gros
la coupe est venu comment vous ça va se
faire l'argent des sommes donc l'idée
c'était de se faire s'affairant l'argent
le vainqueur gagne des vidéos de la
diffuser et de malheureusement non ouf
heureusement d'ailleurs
donc mais je crois que certains veulent
redonner t d'or prix à des associations
aussi j'essaye de contacter une
association caritative pour essayer de
faire un truc mais c'est un peu
compliqué c'est pas sûr qu'on arrive à
le faire aussi rapidement peu importe
c'est un autre sujet
donc l'idée s'arrêter de sélectionner
huit joueurs donc huit participants s'en
flatte parce que trop fort voilà il faut
qu'il ya un peu de suspense cible à 2
joue en fait la compétition n'a aucun
intérêt
j'aime bien le flat de ne joue pas à
rouiba cécile en fait à quoi ça sert ni
aucun enjeu donc on ne peut rien faire
bon ce soir quel est le score à tel
point vlad serait magna ni mais
laisserait des 2000 points donc en gros
il ya plusieurs joueurs sont pressentis
qui ont déjà plus ou moins dit oui
d'ailleurs y'a pas qu'il ai pas rajouté
minorité macro aussi
et donc il est serait de faire un
tableau genre quarts de finale demi
finales finale
les matches se jouent en cadence 3 + 2
en deux sets gagnants de quelqu un à six
il gagne 7 à 3 les sets sont à trois
points en trois points gagnants de cette
comme aux fléchettes donc dès qu'un gars
à troyes il gagne 1,7
ok donc c'est des petits sets
c'est comme ça en trois plus de 1,7 tu
vois si il s'unit à 3 2 ghz ont
peut-être deux points d'écart nom de 3
203 2 et 3 2 c'est si ça arrive à 3 3 il
ya un tie break mais sinon c'est 3 2
blancs noirs blancs noirs blancs warfare
attend à 23,3 en besoin pardonne me
denis obligent leur est d'accord oui non
d'accord c'est sa chance et donc si tu
arrives à si tu arrives à 3 3 la wii
tie-break en + 0 peut donc ça ce serait
du coup donc ouais donc tu arrives pas
tu fais trois deux premiers sets
bon bah deuxième set tu perds trois de
troisième set sinon c'est gagné du coup
ça et
et donc ouais donc quarts de finale demi
finales finale où tous les matches enfin
je pense un format beaucoup plus
intéressant que les speech est donc
c'était l'idée de de faire un truc sais
pas quel point sa voie et sa voix il
peut pas l'air ouais ça arrive personne
fêtant peut-être ont fait pas du tout
enfin tu as et une idée et c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit c'est on ne sait pas
comment ça peut ça peut se faire que si
mal si on peut enfin je pense c'est bien
ça on peut le faire caritatif mais il
faut encore y arriver
bah ça serait bien de le faire caritatif
om et honnêtement c'est pas si simple
que ça maintenant je souhaite que
l'argent aille direct sur le bon truc on
puisse donner que trop de bons
partenaires du coup c'était un ouais
donc c'est pas si simple que ça mais ça
aurait été cool de le faire caritatif
oui bien sûr je donne au tout je ne veux
pas un centime dans cette coupe mais en
fait là pour le vent le salon une sphère
caritatif c'est que les joueurs donnent
s'ils veulent donner ou pas pour le 11
mai mais la difficile live la cup mike
plus que les candidats pour avoir une
wild card
mais peut-être de nouveau de cardin
reiko non mais on verra c'était l'idée
va voir comment c'est possible de
l'organiser tutorat mais bon je pense on
aura le temps un peu pendant tout le
mois d'avril
ouais voilà ça aurait été bien de faire
ça aurait été bien de voir la commencer
dans une dizaine de jours on va voir
beaucoup de streamer et facilement à
trouver des formules caritatif vous
allez trouver
mouais mais après je sais qu'aux états
unis c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
plus féroce et a peu de streamer en
france je connais pas tous creamer
français dans les échecs en tout cas de
gens qu'on pourrait contacter qu'ils
l'ont fait donc il y aura pas de wild
card un abonné puisque si c'est pour un
abonné se prendre 14 0 contre baky
baishi mais annonce un fort il faut
qu'on réussisse à faire un truc bien et
on va on va essayer de trouver de faire
ce qu'on peut
si vous avez des cités ou quoi
n'existait pas mais voilà pour toi
n'hésitez pas à écrire non des idées des
trucs sympas soyez créatifs
on s'amuse un peu donc je peux contacter
je contactais absolue éventuellement je
suis dans l'absolu match je pars pas
qu'il est qu'il ait fait ce genre de
révolte robert s à la vitrine cup
vous êtes pour une deuxième édition wen
dans maple peut-être que même si s'il
n'a pas fait lui directement il peut
peut-être donner un conseil c'est moi
qui sait mais comment faire il connaît
quelqu'un et prendre sept et un huitième
qu'ils ont concertation histoire et ça
va être pire que si je joue seul en fait
des concertations c'est vaut mieux jouer
seul camp concertation en fait
concertation c'est pire que rien on a
essayé vaujour n'a souffert que wave et
même là tu as comptage la partie de
terreur qu'on se parle effacé horrible
en fait mais alors là l'histoire c'était
l'idée c'était de faire un truc
franco-français mais non mais après les
matchs des communautés la team est tout
ça ça serait bien
on environ l'en but laisse son problème
truc
donc voilà du coup donc il y aura huit
joueurs doit y aller on a déjà 5 et puis
enfin éventuellement et puis on verra
mais l'objectif soir des gens très fort
et qui est pas de gens qui se prennent
une raclée ou quoi c'est d'avoir des
joueurs forts qui ce qu'ils fassent des
matchs intéressants quoi bon du coup on
verra si on réussit à donner vie à ce
projet et voilà c'était c'était une idée
et ben on se retrouve demain du coup
demain donc midi et puis prendra pas le
truc plutôt au blitz témoins ouais je
peux en verra on verra comment ça se
passera demain on ajustera en temps
voulu là pour le moment beaucoup de
choses qui se passent merci à tous